Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du deine diplomatische Sondermission erfolgreich abschließen können?
Teils, teils. Also wir befinden uns da noch in den Diskussionen, aber im Allgemeinen sieht's gut aus für das Supreme Council of Cyberspace.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer eins fünf sechs und die Nuss ist wieder da. Musstest ausfallen, weil du warst ja wichtig, wichtig unterwegs. Im weißen Haus. Im weißen Haus.
Im weißen Haus. Im weißen Haus. Nicht drin, aber fast. In Washington. Washington DC.
In welchem weißen Haus? In Washington. Wirklich, DC. Okay. Und äh wie wie tief haben sie dich reingelassen?
Foto vor der Tür.
Wow, wow, ist ja sehr, das ist ja exklusiv.
Nee, auf dem alleine auf dem Foto sind zehn andere drauf, die das Haus auch grade fotografieren.
Aber kein Selfie.
Nee, Selfies mache ich nicht. Das ist affig. Ja. Ich habe letztens aus Versehen ein Selfie gemacht ähm,
Und dann habe ich gesehen, dass das auf dem iPhone sogar jetzt eine eigene Kategorie gibt, Selfies.
Also es wird dann anders sein, ne? Gehen die Leute wohin und fotografieren sich selber. Können sie auch zu Hause machen? Ist doch ein totaler Quatsch.
Ja, aber das.
Nee, mache ich nicht mit.
Leute wollten sich schon immer selbst fotografieren, bloß bis
musste man halt immer jemanden bitten, das zu tun und jetzt, wo man das halt einfach so an der ausgestreckten Hand äh tun kann, warum nicht? Also ich finde das jetzt erstmal nicht grundsätzlich schlecht, aber äh solange,
Face, Duckface von dem und, und, und Hip Hop, Pose, vor dem äh Wild House posiert hast, ist ja alles in Ordnung eigentlich. Auch wenn ich mir das jetzt gerade bildlich sehr schön vorstellen kann.
Also äh wie wie ist nochmal dieser Spruch? Äh,
Events, das und ich würde sagen, der ist meins, machen Fotos von sich selber.
Weg Selfies.
Ja ich, also ich beschäftige mich lieber mit anderen Dingen so. Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe weißt du.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Selfie, der hat ja immer eine gute Ausrede. Ja, ich brauche einen neuen Avatar irgendwie. Geht man ja nicht zum Fotografen, oder?
Ich musste halt einfach irgendwann mal genau, das ist das letzte Selfie, was ich gemacht habe, ist mein Avatar. Aber was äh ähm,
Ich musste halt irgendwann einsehen, ja, dass meine grandiosität ein Grenzen kennt und das weiße Haus wichtiger ist als ich,
Deswegen habe ich dann das Weiße Haus fotografiert und nicht mich.
Weil du das meinst, dass das weiße Haus wichtiger ist oder weil das Weiße Haus meint, dass es wichtiger ist als du.
Weil wir im objektiven Vergleich so im in Einfluss auf die allgemeine Politik, dann ich den Kürzeren ziehen musste, also historisch.
Aber wenn man so deine Medienpräsenz des Jahres mal so zurückblättert in den letzten Monaten so, würde ich sagen,
Auf jeden Fall, ja, bist du auf jeden Fall äh also da trending äh.
Training Toppic. Ja, Toppic, wie gesagt, Toppics, Toppics sind mir eigentlich wichtiger, ja.
Ja, Trending Topics.
Aber macht ihr ruhig Selfies? Das ist ja auch gut, äh aber äh ähm ach, da gab's auch so ein wunderschönes Zitat bei dem äh bei dem,
Geheimtreffen in ähm in Washington, wo äh gesagt wurde,
Ich habe mir die besten, schönen Sprüche äh.
Hast du den notiert, obwohl es ein Treffen war, wo keine Notizen gemacht werden durften, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist ja genau der, das ist ja genau der Trick.
Und keine Selfies.
Weil meine habe ich gar nicht mehr. Äh so irgendwie sowas wie äh,
Das würde ich das finde ich sehr gut, ja.
Nun denn, ähm.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich wollte ich noch was sagen?
Du kannst ja einfach äh feiern, dass wir jetzt mal wieder in der Mieterebene zusammengekommen sind. Ich habe extra einen neuen Tisch.
Ich, hör mal, ich feiere einiges. Ich feiere, dass ich wahrscheinlich mit diesen äh letzten Trip wahrscheinlich bis zum Ende des Jahres äh den Kontinent nicht mehr verlassen werde und das finde ich eigentlich echt gut.
Bist ein bisschen viel gereist dieses Jahr, ne?
Nicht mal so viel wie im letzten Jahr.
Aber immer noch ausreichend, um äh ausgelaugt rüberzukommen.
Ja. Ja, noch nicht mal, also noch nicht mal so viel, wie im letzten Jahr. Letztes Jahr war's mehr.
Ich bin für meinen Geschmack zu wenig gereist, aber da komme ich auch von einer anderen Basis.
So ist das, ne? Es gefällt einem immer, wie es ist. Watte machst, machste falsch. Was die anderen machen, machen sie auch falsch und wie ist es immer scheiße?
Ja und das Gras ist immer grüner auf der anderen Seite des Teppichs oder wieder.
Ein, zwei Länder, in die du getingelt bist, da würde ich auch gerne mal wieder hin. Aber kommen wir.
Reinlassen.
Wenn sie mich reinlassen oder rauslassen oder was auch immer, ja.
Das ist ja eigentlich immer der Witz, wenn man wenn man in die USA reist, dass man halt bei der Einreise steht und sagt so, was ist mir eigentlich jetzt lieber?
Reinlassen oder dass sie mich nicht reinlassen.
Im Prinzip so nicht reinlassen wäre ja noch das Ehrlichste. Sage ich auch immer, ein Hirn so, ha, ich kann nicht in die USA reisen, also es gibt wenige Personen, die echt nicht in die USA reisen können, ja, weil die werden reingelassen.
Aber nicht raus. Aber nicht raus. Mhm.
Aber nicht raus, aber der größere Teil ähm denke ich mal, da braucht man sich jetzt echt keine großartigen Sorgen zu machen.
Ja, ist aber auch schon hip heutzutage, ne? Also da kann.
Nicht in die USA reisen zu können.
Kann man so rumkoketieren und so.
Ja, aber da muss man auch für arbeiten. Da muss man was für tun. Ja, nur weil man irgendwie mal einen Kongress besucht hat, äh äh ist man noch nicht auf der No-Fly-Liste. Da muss man schon irgendwie,
Falsches twittern oder äh ein Flugzeug haken oder so.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, bemühen wir uns einfach mal so ein bisschen für ein Einreiseverbot. Mal gucken, ob äh unsere heutige Themenliste da schon ausreicht.
Naja, das ist er, na ja, reisen in die USA.
Ja
Ja, also äh Antrag auf äh Ausreiseverbot stellen hier auch einige Leute unserer politischen äh,
Oberkaste hier. Und äh möchte gerne äh mit Wattenborsch hier beworfen werden für den Beschluss,
Anspeicherung, die steht nämlich jetzt an. Ähm CDU und SPD Hand in Hand.
Große Koalition.
Große Koalition zieht voran und ist
unbeirrbar und äh möchte also gerne ihre tolle neue Variante, Vorratsdatenspeicherung leiht, jetzt äh,
mehr Schoko oder was auch immer Sie meinen, was Sie jetzt da nennenswert geändert haben, durchbringen, nachdem es ja den Kabinettsbeschluss schon gab, äh wandert das Ganze jetzt in den Bundestag
wo eben mit der knappen Mehrheit der großen Koalition das Ding bestimmt noch total auf der Kante steht.
Ne, dass äh das Krasse ist ja eigentlich, dass wir das gestern erfahren haben,
Also ich habe irgendwie ähm am Dienstag irgendwie so,
Kurznachricht äh von meinen äh Quellen im Bundestag erhalten äh von meinen Landesverrätern im Bundestag. Äh da sind ja sowieso alles Verräter. Ähm
wie wir wissen, ähm die das irgendwie am, dass sie am Mittwoch in die Ausschüsse geht, also jetzt gerade in den Rechtsausschuss, heute ist Mittwoch,
Und am Freitag im Plenum zweite und dritte Lesung, zack. Alphafan, so macht man das, ja und ähm das Einzige, was darin jetzt geändert wurde, ähm.
Gegenüber dem,
Entwurf, den wir ursprünglich gesehen haben, ja? Ähm ist, dass es also eine Evaluierungsklausel gibt,
Also ne, es wird alles so, wie wir es besprochen haben, äh sowohl durch Ausschuss Schüsse als auch durch zweite und dritte Lesung am Freitag gehen,
Das Einzige, was drin ist, ist eine ein äh Änderungsantrag der Fraktion CDU, CSU und SPD. Ähm,
Und darin wird ein Artikel sieben Evaluierung hinzugefügt. Und der sagt.
Will ich den jetzt nicht. Der ist nicht so lang, aber ich fasse ihn trotzdem mal zusammen. Äh das also,
Interessanterweise etwas, was der CCC ähm also wir,
Grundsätzlich auch hier in der Sendung immer mal wieder gefordert haben. Nämlich, dass man sagt, wenn ihr solche,
Grundrechtseinschränkenden Gesetze beschließt. Dann sollen die bitte ein Verfallsdatum bekommen und,
Zum Ablauf dieses Verfallsdatum wollen wir evaluieren, was ihr da soll öffentlich in der öffentlichen Debatte evaluiert werden, die Wirksamkeit des Gesetzes,
Ja, dass man sagt, okay, wenn ihr sowas macht, dann müsst ihr regelmäßig unter,
müsst ihr regelmäßig darunter Auskunft geben, wobei euch dieses Gesetz jetzt geholfen hat?
Welche welche Ziele ihr mithilfe dieser Grundrechtseinschränkung erreichen könntet? Inwiefern? In wie vielen Fällen?
Und wenn da jetzt das Wirksamkeitskriterium.
Der gesellschaftlichen Debatte nicht erreicht wird, dann.
Möchten wir uns vorbehalten, dieses Gesetz auch wieder abzusetzen. Das war mal die Idee, ähm dieser Forderung, die ähm,
Ich glaube von vielen gestellt wird aber unter anderem auch vom CCC und unter anderem auch von mir mal äh im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda. Der Gedanke ist natürlich, irgendwie ein Mechanismus zu haben, dass diese,
der mehr Überwachung, der mehr Grundrechtseinschränkungen zu einem Ende kommt,
überhaupt, dass es einen Prozess gibt, wo ein Ende entstehen könnte.
Und wir hatten ja übrigens gerade den Fall in den USA mit den Überwachungsgesetzen, dass die ja ausgelaufen sind und hätten,
explizit verlängert werden müssen und das nicht.
Und er hat sich keine.
Getan wurde.
Das sehe ich aber jetzt hier in diesem Änderungsantrag, ehrlich gesagt, so nicht, also hier ist kein äh drin, sondern nur ein na ja, da müssen wir mal ein bisschen evaluieren und wenn man sich so die Formulierungen hier auch anschaut, ne, also.
Die Formulierung, die Formulierung hier sind nämlich äh,
echt interessant. Also hier wird fast, fast das Gleiche gemacht, außer, dass man sagt, okay, das Gesetz läuft nicht aus,
sondern es muss halt evaluiert werden und hier wird gesagt, okay, ähm nach,
nach, nach sechsunddreißig Monaten muss eine Evaluation stattfinden über das Ergebnis der,
Evaluation ist im Deutschen Bundestag Bericht zu erstatten, Freitagabend um zweiundzwanzig Uhr oder so. Die Evaluierung ist unter Einbeziehung eines oder eines ein Jahr oder eines wissenschaftlichen Sachverständigen vorzunehmen.
Wird wieder so einer in den Keller gesperrt.
Die, die oder der im Einvernehmen mit dem Deutschen Bundestag zu bestellen ist,
Ja, also im mit dem Deutschen Bundestag heißt, da wird dann drüber abgestimmt in der großen Koalition. Ähm
Die Evaluierung erfolgt unter Auswertung der Übersicht gemäß Paragraph einhunderteins B der Strafprozessordnung zu evaluieren sind. Jetzt interessant. Frage eins. Die Auswirkung dieses Gesetzes auf die Strafverfolgung und die Gefahrenabwehr. Das heißt,
im Prinzip Wirksamkeit, ne? Hat dieses Gesetz dazu beigetragen,
Das mehr Straftaten aufgeklärt werden konnten ähm oder,
mehr Gefahr abgewehrt wurde, sind zum Beispiel bestimmte Straftaten zurückgegangen, weil man sie in dem Risiko der Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht mehr so einfach begehen kann.
Zweitens, die durch dieses Gesetz, für die Wirtschaft und die Verwaltung verursachten Kosten. Ja, also was hat das Ganze gekostet? Das ist dann so eine äh Kosten,
Abrechnung auf finanzieller Ebene, ne? Wie viel Geld haben wir ausgegeben.
Wo war das teuer?
War teuer gewesen,
ne? Und dann, drittens, die Einhaltung der datenschutzrechtlichen Regelungen. Ja, wurde gegen den Datenschutz verstoßen. Niemals wird gegen den Datenschutz verstoßen. Das kennen wir ja schon vom Datenschutz.
Und das ist ja erstmal nicht.
Also ist erstmal nicht verkehrt sowas zu machen. Und dann kommt der letzte Satz. Der Evaluierungsbericht soll auch möglichen Handlungsbedarf für eine wirksamere Strafverfolgung und Gefahrenabwehr benennen,
Hierbei ist die Fortentwicklung der Kommunikationstechnik zu berücksichtigen. Und das ist.
Strafverschärfungsparagraphsklausel.
Das heißt im Prinzip und das, das ist auch genau die Falle, die die ich jetzt bei dieser ganzen Evaluationsthematik natürlich auch immer wieder gesehen habe.
Wenn sie eben nicht mit dem Auslaufen des Gesetzes verbunden ist. Weil was wird jetzt passieren? Wir haben jetzt die diese Vorratsdatenspeicher oder wir werden jetzt diese Vorzeitenspeicherung bekommen, die etwas ähm weniger,
Vorhaltefristen hat als die erste Vorratsseitensprechung, die wir hatten. Und jetzt wird in drei Jahre gegeben. Sie haben's ja,
Im Prinzip hat ja bis jetzt noch kein Land, in dem es vor Seitenspeicherung gibt oder gab, ähm.
Äh belastbare oder überhaupt irgendwelche Zahlen für eine Wirksamkeit vorlegen können. Es gibt einfach keine Studien, die gesagt haben,
hier Gefahrenabwehr und Strafverfolgung im Sinne des Gesetzes,
Effektivität gezeigt. Gibt's einfach nicht. Zumindest keine ernstzunehmenden. Und die
Begründung, die du natürlich von den Vorratsdatenspeicherungsbefürwortern hörst, warum es die nicht gibt, ist ja ähm die Vorratsseitensprechung gab's ja dann auch nur so kurz, dass der Effekt noch gar nicht
zu erwarten ist nach anderthalb oder zwei Jahren. Das muss sich ja auch erstmal rumsprechen in den Behörden. Die äh Beamten müssen ja erstmal wissen, dass sie dieses neue Mittel zur Verfügung haben, ne. Die Schreibmaschine zur Seite schieben und so,
Ähm das wird also gesagt.
Nur dass es halt in den anderen Ländern, wo es durchgehend Forst, Datenspeicherungen gibt, solche Studien auch nicht gibt, die das.
Genau und das und das beißt sich natürlich auch mit dem Argument, dass sie sagen, ja äh nur wegen mangelnder Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh rennen hier überall Terroristen rum und so, ne, sie sagen ja immer auch so, wir es gibt ja dann auch diese schönen,
Studien möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber so ähm Aufsätze,
Aufsätze, wo da drin steht, welche, wie viel man alles nicht äh aufklären konnte, wegen mangelnder Vorzahnspeicherung. Was ja auch so ein ähm ein, ein
Quatschargument ist, ne? Weil wenn man ein Mittel nicht zur Verfügung hat, dann kann man auch nicht sagen, man hätte es mit Hilfe dieses Mittels aufklären können. Und das ist natürlich
was man für für einen ernst zu nehmenden Evaluierungsbericht verlangen würde,
Jetzt nämlich in jedem einzelnen aufgeklärten Fall, in dem die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zur Anwendung kam, die Beweiskette geprüft wird und und der Nachweis geführt werden muss, ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
wäre dieser Fall garantiert nicht aufgeklärt worden,
Auch das ist natürlich das Argument ist schwer zu führen. Äh und oder dieser Beleg ist schwer zu führen, aber das ist natürlich die notwendige Bedingung dafür, dass du so eine Evaluation überhaupt sinnvoll vornimmst. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal an, also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Sechsunddreißig Monate nach Inkrafttreten, also drei Jahre später, so in drei Jahren. Jetzt gibt's welche Ergebnisse kann dieser Evaluierungsbericht haben? Sagen wir mal, er sagt,
Wirksamkeit, was weiß ich. Zehn Prozent Gefahrenabwehr und äh,
In bestimmten Bereichen, das wird ja sowieso jetzt nicht allgemein sein, das ist ja sehr deliktspezifisch, ne? Eins, was ja ein Problem, was immer angeführt ist, ist der Enkeltrick. Ja, rufst irgendwo an und sagst,
Bei einer beim äh bei einer bei einer Seniorenperson an und sagst.
Mister Enkel.
Der Enkel und Bros braucht ganz viel, Bros, alles Geld, was sie haben so, ne. Und das äh funktioniert offenbar erstaunlich gut,
Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, mit einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung kriegt man da eventuell äh bessere Ermittlungserfolge, weil das auch wohl
organisierte Kriminalität ist sie das macht, das ist nicht irgendwie sind nicht Leute, die sich irgendwie mal nachmittags denken, probiere ich mal aus, sondern es sind Leute, die das andauernd machen, die das äh die da auch eine Aufgabenteilung drin haben, das sind,
Gruppen organisierte Gruppen, die das machen, ne. Könnte man natürlich sagen, so okay, äh,
Da das eben der Erstkontakt immer über Telefonate stattfindet, könnte man eventuell hoffen, dass man da äh erhöhte Gefahrenabwehr und,
bessere Ermittlungserfolge,
erreicht. Klammer auf, diejenigen, die das machen, wissen natürlich auch, dass es dann eine Vorzeitspeicherung gibt und geben halt ein paar Euro mehr für Prepaid äh Handys aus oder so, ne, oder gehen in den Telefonzellen, also das wird schon das wird arbeiten,
gesetzt den Fall, so. Dann wird man natürlich sagen, okay,
fünf fünf oder zehn Prozent äh Rückgang dieser Straftaten, dann wird die Interpretation sein, wenn wir jetzt die,
ausdehnen, wenn wir noch längere Daten haben, dann kriegen wir zwanzig Prozent Rückgang. Also Schluss, die Schlussfolgerung aus ähm,
Wirksamkeit wird sein.
Erweitern, weil die Wirksamkeit wird nicht einhundert Prozent sein. Rückgang wird, wenn überhaupt, in irgendeinem äh niedrigen Einstieg bis zweistelligen Prozentbereich liegen,
und dann müsstest du aber noch herausrechnen, dass eventuell einfach andere Straftaten in Mode kommen.
Also was was ist mit dem Gesamtlevel an Kriminalitäten machen, die vielleicht jetzt einfach andere Sachen, ja? Äh oder,
Wurden halt durch ein paar Ermittlungserfolge die entscheidenden Banden geschnappt und jetzt macht's keiner mehr. Ne?
Schluss, dass man sagt, ach, nur zehn Prozent oder nur fünf Prozent. Scheiß drauf, dann können wir das. Das ist natürliche Schwankungen innerhalb eines Jahres. Oder innerhalb von von drei Jahren, ähm,
Da können wir das Mittel wieder abschaffen, die dies da trotzdem wieder nicht zulässig, ne?
So, zweiter, zweite Möglichkeit, also das heißt, wenn man wenig Effektivität nachweist, dann wird,
Ist die logische Schlussfolgerung ausweiten, weil die fehlende Effektivität des Mittels wird darauf atribuiert werden, dass,
die Speicherfrist nicht lang genug sind. Wenn es keine Effektivität zeigt,
wird man sagen, ja, wie gesagt, ist ja auch erst drei Jahre, die Dienststellen müssen sich erst dran gewöhnen und zweitens,
Müssen wir natürlich die Speicherfristen ausweiten, weil das Mittel hat ja keine Effektivität gezeichnet. Das liegt ja genau daran, dass wir so cool zur Speicherfristen haben.
Ne? Und wenn sich jetzt eine, wenn sich jetzt in bestimmten Delikten eine Effektivität zeigt und diese auch wirklich, sagen wir mal, zufriedenstellend ist. Ich gehe, wie gesagt, davon aus, dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Dann wird man sagen, na ja okay und was ist mit dem Deliktbereichen, in denen wir keine höheren Aufklärungsraten bekommen haben? Wie können wir da auch so tolle Ermittlungserfolge erzielen? Wie.
Wie können wir, ne, die die gesamte Kriminalität stilllegen? Und da kommt natürlich dann dieser dieser Absatz äh äh zum Tragen,
Wir wollen möglichen Handlungsbedarf für eine wirksame Strafverfolgung und Gefahrenabwehr benennen. Das heißt, diese Evaluierung wird am Ende.
Wieder nur ein eine Grundrechtseinschränkungsverschärfung herbeiführen. Also es gibt auch hier wieder äh ist ein eine gerichtete,
Evaluierung, die irgendwie den Umkehrschluss wieder nicht zulässt, ne, wie so wie alle Studien, die irgendwelche äh Lobbyisten in in Auftrag geben, ne?
Sehr genügt eben nicht ernsthaften wissenschaftlichen Kriterien spannend wäre, jetzt zu sagen, okay Freunde, wir setzen Ziele, ja?
So würde so würde man das ja ein Unternehmen machen bei Investitionen und bei Einschränkungen, dass man sagt, okay Freunde.
Nicht das und das eingetreten ist.
Das und das und das und das wollen wir haben, ja? Und wenn das nicht, wenn ihr nicht äh nachweisen könnt, dass ihr das
dass dass euer Programm hier Effektivität zeigt, dann wird das sofort abgesägt nach nach Evaluat Evaluationszeitraum. Das haben wir hier nicht. Das ist also der Änderungsantrag, der da drin ist. Alles andere genauso, wie bei uns jetzt schon mehrfach ähm besprochen,
Insbesondere natürlich auch der ähm,
nicht unerhebliche Absatz zur Datenhelerei, wo ja sowieso irgendwie unklar ist, was hat der denn jetzt mit ähm,
mit mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun.
Warte mal kurz, bevor wir äh auf die Heerei kommen. Ähm nochmal zu dieser Evaluierung
Also es gibt ja noch diesen dritten Punkt, ne, die Einhaltung der Datenschutz rechtlichen Regelungen soll ja auch äh evaluiert werden. Das ist, sagen wir mal, hier noch das einzige
abgesehen ist von den Kosten Rechnungen, wo ich sagen würde, okay, hier könnte ja im Prinzip auch eine Evaluierung stattfinden, äh die eine Aussage darüber macht, so wie viel Grundrechte, Verletzungen
sozusagen hier durch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgelöst,
Aber es ist halt, sagen wir mal, auch in dem Ton dieses ganzen Absatzes keinerlei äh also es wird irgendwie nicht offen gelassen, dass das sehr wohl auch zu einer Abschaffung führen könnte.
Ja, sondern es ist das einzige, was hier quasi äh drin ist, ist, na ja, wir müssen das mal evaluieren und dann müssen wir mal uns auch mal erklären lassen, was mögliche Handlungsbedarf ist für eine,
Wie sie das nennen, wirksamere Strafverfolgung, ja, wo quasi nur eigentlich die Verschärfung im Ton drin ist. Ich frage mich, ob sowas vom juristischen Stil her,
Eigentlich, schauen wir mal. Zulässig ist es vielleicht, aber
ja, ob das zum guten Ton äh äh gehört in der in der Gesetzschreibung, da würde ich jetzt um meine Zweifel haben, weiß ich natürlich wieder nicht, hier äh Juristen, die hier zuhören, dürfen sich gerne mal zu dieser Formulierung
äußern, ob sowas äh generell fragwürdig ist, auch wenn's jetzt nicht viel bringen wird. Also es ist schon äh so eine Sache, aber man hat zumindest noch diesen Absatz drei nur,
nirgendswo atmet dieser Absatz oder über dieser dieser ganze Paragraph äh äh eine eine mögliche Sanktionierung äh gegen dieses Gesetz.
So, Datenhellerei ist ja neu, gab's vorher so in dieser Form oder zumindest in dieser Formulierung nicht.
Und das hat sich ja jetzt hier auch noch mit eingeschlichen.
Genau, Datenhellerei, Paragraph zweihundertzwei D. Ähm wird jetzt in mit dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung Gesetzgebung ja auch noch eingeführt,
Und der lautet, äh wer Daten, die nicht allgemein zugänglich sind und die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat,
sich oder einem anderen verschafft, einem anderen überlässt, verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht,
um sich oder einen dritten zu bereichern,
oder einen anderen zu schädigen, wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft.
Die Strafe darf nicht schwerer sein, als die für die Vortat angedrohte Strafe. Also du darfst jetzt als wenn die, wenn die die äh rechtswidrige Tat geringer bestraft wird, als
veröffentlichen, dann du darfst nicht höher bestraft werden als derjenige oder diejenige, die die Daten durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, ja? Ähm
Absatz eins gilt nicht Verhandlungen,
die ausschließlich der Erfüllung rechtmäßiger dienstlicher oder beruflicher Pflichten dienen. Dazu gehören insbesondere solche Handlungen von Amtsträgern oder deren Beauftragten
Daten ausschließlich der Verwertung in einem Besteuerungsverfahren, einem Strafverfahren oder einem Ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren zugeführt werden sollen.
Ist wirklich kompliziert, aber pass auf.
Darf sich weiterhin CDs in der Schweiz kaufen, aber äh Journalisten dürfen nicht Überwachung dokumentieren.
Es gibt es gibt eine andere Person,
durch eine rechtswidrige Tatdaten erlangt hat. Das ist hier grundsätzlich, also dies, die steht in einem anderen Paragraphen, ja? Dieser Paragraph betrifft nun jene Personen, denen sich die diese Person anvertraut.
Beispielsweise ein Journalist oder ein Steuerfahnder, ja?
Und diese zweite Person, also Empfänger der illegal erlangten Daten, um die handelt dieser Paragraph. Jetzt bin ich der Empfänger. Wenn ich diese nun.
Verschaffe oder einem anderen verschaffe oder einem anderen überlasse oder verbreite oder sogar öffentlich mache.
Dann steht das unter Strafe, sofern ich dies tue, um mich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen.
Also Whistleblower gibt mir Daten, die sind noch nicht bekannt. Ich veröffentliche sie,
mit dem Ziel, mich oder jemand anderen zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen. Nehmen wir mal als Beispiel äh weil's so schön ist, Andre von Netzpolitik org,
kriegt Daten, die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, ja? Ähm überlässt sie jetzt anderen. Das kann jetzt zum Beispiel äh tun, wenn er sie ähm,
einem Experten zur Einschätzung gibt vor der Veröffentlichung. Andre macht ja dann immer schön diese äh Zusammenfassung von Statements von allen möglichen äh Würdenträgern,
ähm schon Datenhederei,
Er verbreitet sie auf Netzpolitik Org ja oder er macht sie zugänglich, aber entscheidend ist, tut er dies um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen? Klar, erfüllt Netzpolitik org ähm möchte Geld verdienen.
Reich werden.
Möchte reich werden, die bereichern sich an ihrer,
bereichern sich an ihrer Tätigkeit, ja? Ähm und,
man könnte unter Umständen den etwas schwierigen Beweis führen, äh dass es Andres Motivation war, einen anderen zu schädigen. Ne, nämlich zum Beispiel das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Ähm.
Ähm das ist aber eine infame Unterstellung.
Der Nachweis ist ist schwieriger zu führen, ne, weil er natürlich auch andererseits im im Auftrag oder aus einer äh politischen Erwähnung heraus äh seiner Tätigkeit nachkommt, aber man sieht, wie schwierig das ist,
Ausnahme. Andre,
ähm zum Beispiel für irgendeine Behörde, kriegt eine illegale Steuer-CD und gibt die Daten äh weiter an äh ne, an die an die Steuerfahndung oder an wen auch immer, äh um um diese illegal erlangten Daten,
In einem Strafverfahren oder in einem Ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren oder einem Besteuerungsverfahren zu verwenden. Wir erinnern uns, dass mit.
Dann gibt's Blumen und es wird auf dem Flug geklatscht.
Nee, das ist in Ordnung. So, also das war ja, das war ja die große Debatte mit diesen, mit diesen Steuer-CDs, dass wir ja im Prinzip unseren Gerichten.
Erlaubt haben illegale Tätigkeiten zu äh decken.
Dass wir ursprünglich unseren Gerichten verboten haben, ähm auf illegalem Wege erlangte Beweismittel zu verwenden,
Polizist, seine, wenn ein Polizist seine äh Grenzen überschreitet, denn da dürfen die dadurch erlangen Beweise äh,
sollten nicht unbedingt in einem Gerichtsverfahren zur Verwendung zur Anwendung kommen. In den USA ist das sehr viel strenger, wenn du da als Polizist irgendwie eine auch nur,
nicht auf korrektem Wege erlangten Beweis in deiner Beweiskette hast, dann fliegt dir das ganze Verfahren um die Ohren, was.
Was natürlich im bestimmten Fällen dann auch ärgerlich sein kann für die äh für die Gesellschaft, wenn's um irgendwie üble Kriminelle geht. Andererseits aber die die einzige wirksame Methode ist, Polizisten,
sehr klar zu machen, dass sie ihre Grenzen keinesfalls überschreiten sollen. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind in Deutschland, wird da etwas anders mit umgegangen,
Also da fällt dir nicht direkt das ganze Verfahren ins Wasser, ne? Das dann darfst du halt diesen einen Beweis nicht vorbringen, aber eventuell alle anderen, die du vielleicht in Folge dessen äh mit an dich.
Steht aber dann trotzdem im Raum und die Sanktionen ist halt nicht da.
Genau, ja. Also zumindest nicht in der Härte wie in den USA. So, was heißt dieser.
Komplett auf den Kopf gestellt. So, jetzt wird sozusagen explizit auch illegal erlangte äh Daten, die auf der einen Seite ja so unglaublich illegal sind, ja, dass man sie noch nicht mal anfassen darf,
Und hier äh darf halt der Staat das tun, äh weil er ja immer alles richtig macht und genau. Der Journalist darf es halt.
Darf ja sowieso jetzt interessant. Ulf Burmeier schreibt dazu, also weil gerade dieses mit dem Bereichern oder andere zu schädigen, weil das so schwammig ist, ne? Hm,
schreibt er,
Welches Verhalten wird künftig klar unter Strafe gestellt? Zum Beispiel, dass ein Journalist daten, die auf vertraulichem Weg von einem Whistleblower erhalten hat, vertraulich an Experten zur Prüfung
oder an einen Zeitungsredakteur zur Einschätzung übergibt,
Es reicht aus, dass Experte und Redakteur sich die Daten, zum Beispiel eine Word oder PDF-Datei auf einen USB-Stick überspielen, schon haben sie sich künftig strafbar gemacht, so die Interpretation des,
Juristen.
Großartig.
Ja und ich ich ziehe da jetzt Ulf spezifisch heran, weil äh ich ja äh mich zu juristischen Themen nicht qualifiziert fühle. Ähm.
Ähm ich auch nicht.
Spannend und das wird, das bleibt da einfach mit drin. Also er hat sich dann noch weiter darüber ähm ausgelassen, was also auch der der Begriff der Hehlerei da drin bedeutet und ähm,
wo der eigentlich herkommt und warum man diese Idee mal hatte, ne, da stellt man sich ja anfangs was anderes vor. Also wenn jemand sagt, wir machen jetzt was gegen Datenhellerei, würde ich sagen, alles klar.
Jeder, der mit irgendwelchen,
Ähm auf Rechtswege erlangten Daten Handel betreibt, das ist verboten, ja? Steuer-CD gerne, ja, aber muss für sein. Kannst du nicht, äh kannst du nicht zum Verkauf anbieten. Das ist,
das ist grundsätzlich ja vielleicht erstmal keine so doofe Erwägung.
Aber dann kriegt man die halt auch nicht.
Ja eben, kriegst du halt nicht, ne. Und du genau,
Also und,
Okay, dieser Paragraf ist auch mit drin. Das ist noch das Weitere äh das das zweite dicke Ei in diesem ganzen Vorratsdatenspeicherungsding, dass wir da eine äh eine Erschwerung der Arbeit von von Whistleblowern ganz klar drin haben.
Ja, am Freitag schon soll's äh beschlossen werden. Ähm,
Am Freitag gibt es dann auch eine eine Demonstration vor dem Bundestag, aber mehr oder weniger ist schon echt krass, ne, sowas irgendwie man sieht, wie's hier gemacht wird, ne? Dienstag bekannt geben, Freitag beschließen.
Zweite, dritte Lesung, alles in einem Durchgang. Das kennt man dann auch, das kann man sich wahrscheinlich dann schön wieder im Bundestag Videostream anschauen, die dann so die zweite und dritte Lesung so innerhalb von zwanzig Sekunden äh durchgeführt wird. Da wird dann so kurz die Hand hochgehoben und dann.
Paar Gegenreden zu Protokoll.
Genau, da wird halt nicht geredet im Parolament, sondern da wird halt geblockt.
Ja und dann ist das erledigt. Gut, ähm wie geht's weiter? Müssen wir auch sagen, ähm Verfassungsklage äh kommt sofort. Techniker ist informiert. Das wird natürlich irgendwie,
sofort den den geregelten Weg gehen.
Ja, Sabine Lloydhäuser Schnarrenberger mit Flammenschwert voran.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer da jetzt diesmal ja, aber alle.
Die hat's schon angekündigt, dass sie das tun wollen würde. Ja, klar, Baum.
Das Alte genau, das alte Bau, äh das alte.
Nicht äh.
Nochmal zusammen.
Wieso den in diesen wunderbaren Spielfilmen oder so,
die alten äh bombenspezialisten und so weiter zusammengesucht werden. Ja, wir haben nochmal einen Einsatz und dann müssen sie um so ein fernes Diktator an Land fahren, um da dann irgendwie nochmal alles auszuhebeln.
Ich glaube, in der Rolle mögen sie sich dann auch. Aber ist ja auch in Ordnung. Mach das mal. Ähm ja, aber das unangenehme ist halt, es muss halt jetzt erstmal wieder diese Bürde aufgenommen werden. Die ganze VDS äh steht da eigentlich drin, ab wann die gelten soll,
Ähm ist das dann schon Anfang nächsten Jahres oder sofort.
Du stellst immer Fragen.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Also es, ich glaube, dass das in Kraft das Datum ist, in Krafttretens noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher,
Weil in dem Änderungsantrag, den ich gerade noch offen hatte, stand drin, äh hier Datum des Inkrafttretens eintragen. Aber ich meine, mich zu erinnern, dass in dem,
Gesetzesentwurf, den ich gerade noch offen hatte und jetzt geschlossen hatte, weil ich zum nächsten Thema wollte, ein Datum des Inkrafttretens drin stand.
Du hast gesagt, du hättest ihn auch geöffnet, also kannst du hier mal.
Ich hatte auch nur den Änderungsantrag äh offen und habe ihn nicht mehr offen.
Dann frag doch nicht so weit. Arschloch. Freitag also Demo. Ich bin mal gespannt. Das äh kann man sich ja vorstellen äh die wird natürlich nicht so.
Nicht so groß werden wahrscheinlich, ne. Wir hatten wir haben ja jetzt wenige Tage Mobilisierungszeit. Ähm aber es gab eine sehr große Demut, ähm.
Gegen Tittete. Viel Tees. Eine der größten bin ich.
Eine der größten, so eine große Demo gab es jahrelang nicht mehr in Berlin.
Ja, es waren alle etwas überrascht und die Zahlen sind auch etwas unklar, äh aber wenn schon die Polizei von hundertfünfzig äh tausend äh spricht, dann ähm dann ist äh einiges da gewesen.
Veranstalter sagen zweihundertfünfzigtausend Polizei seit hundertfünfzigtausend, ich glaube in der Regel wenn du zwischen beiden einfach die Mitte bildest, hast du eine gute Schätzung und wenn du dir die Fotos anschaust, kann ich mir das auch sehr gut vorstellen.
Zweihunderttausend, sagen wir mal. Wir sagen zweihundert.
Wir sagen, wir sagen zweihunderttausend ohne, dass einer von uns beiden da war. Äh.
Oder auch nur auf die Fotos von oben. Wirklich geguckt.
Foto geguckt. Ich habe mal versucht zu zählen, konnte ich jetzt nicht.
Nicht? Ich freue mich auch, warum das noch so ein großes Problem ist mit der heutigen Technik. Sollte es ja eigentlich äh keine größere, kein größeres Problem darstellen, relativ verlässliche äh Teilnehmerzahlen zu verkünden, oder?
Richtig, aber du hast ja jetzt Polizei, äh willst du ja niedriger schätzen und als Veranstalter höher, also hat keiner äh.
Zeit ist immer niedriger schätzen will.
Ach schon, oder?
Na, wenn die GDP da irgendwie am äh demonstrieren ist.
Für die.
Ja oder was auch immer.
Ähm.
Also ich will der Polizei da gar nichts unterstellen. Ich denke, dass sie sich schon ich weiß nicht, ob ob da wirklich so eine ausgeprägte.
Tendenz zu erkennen, dass immer alles niedriger zu schätzen. Sicherlich ist bei Veranstaltern eine Tendenz dazu da, alles immer größer zu schätzen, weil die haben dann nur, sagen wir mal, ein größeres Interesse daran, als die Polizei
Die Polizei ist das, glaube ich, in gewisser Hinsicht eher sinnvoll, der Zahl, also,
Kannst ja gerne ein Gegenargument liefern, aber mir fällt gerade keins ein. Die Polizei sollte ja auch ein Interesse daran haben, dass halbwegs sinnvoll einzuschätzen und nicht immer nur jeden ähm Widerstand runterzurechnen, weil das für sie ja vor allem ein logistische,
größer ist, mit der sie auch argumentieren müssen.
Ja äh also wir wir sind uns darüber einig, dass es wahrscheinlich eine schwierige Aufgabe ist, so viele Leute zu zählen, insbesondere für einen Polizisten und ähm ne, wenn da stehst du eins, ne? Ach, scheiße und dann.
Zähler macht man das ja heutzutage nicht mehr.
Ich weiß, aber können wir vielleicht kurz über die Demo sprechen, bevor wir okay.
Auf der wir nicht waren.
Auf der wir nicht warten. Ja genau, große Demo, auf der wir nicht waren, jetzt erzählen die Blinden wieder von der Farbe. So, das wird aber ich habe mich gestern ausführlich informiert bei,
Menschen, die diese Demo besucht haben. Und ich finde es ja, wir erinnern uns an TTIP, insbesondere natürlich an die Sendung Nummer mit der Nummer einhundertdreißig.
Weiß jetzt nicht ausm Kopf, bis er dann nicht so firm.
Die hieß Radikalisierung durch Internet, da hatten wir.
Ah. Den Gast.
Zu Gast. Und die hat uns äh über Freihandelsabkommen,
erzählt und äh was darin beschlossen wird. Wir erinnern uns eigentlich, geht es ja darum äh den,
den Handel zu harmonisarisieren zwischen äh Staaten und dafür zu äh dafür zu sorgen,
dass eine so die Argumentation eine ein, ein besserer, verbindlichere Rechtsrahmen möglich,
wird, wenn.
Ein ähm ein Unternehmen aus einem einen Land, mit dem in einem anderen Land Handel betreibt,
und da wird dann häufig angeführt, zum Beispiel, dass,
was weiß ich, äh für ein Fahrzeug, das in den USA verkauft wird, andere,
ähm Bestimmungen gelten, was jetzt irgendwie Scheinwerfer oder sagen wir mal die Abgase des Dieselmotors,
betrifft, ja, als äh als in Europa, ja? Und irgendwie muss dieser ganze Kram ja vereinheitlicht werden,
und äh als wenn das nicht einfach schon der Fall wäre, ja, weil die Bedingungen ja bekannt sind, ähm,
Was zum Beispiel ein Dieselmotor in den USA ausstoßen darf und man auch weiß, wie man einen Dieselmotor dahin programmiert, unter bestimmten Bedingungen auch diese Grenzen einzuhalten. Ähm.
Sollte das ja eigentlich jetzt nicht so das Problem sein, aber heraufbeschworen wird immer, ja, da gibt's so ganz viel und vor allem ist ja schwierig, wenn,
Man langfristige Investitionen tätigt, wie zum Beispiel äh den Bau eines Atomkraftwerks ist teuer.
Atomkraftwerk ist teuer und diese Investition tätigt man natürlich nur, wenn man,
sich einigermaßen sicher sein kann, dass diese Investition sich auch ähm auszahlen wird. Und da ist es, kommt das natürlich sehr ungünstig,
Wenn im im im Zielland, dass ja in der Regel nicht das Eigene ist, ja, ähm,
Auf einmal einen Atomausstieg beschlossen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, ne. Dann geht einem ja äh eingebildeter Gewinn durch die Lappen. Und für einen solchen Fall möchte man dann,
Als Unternehmen natürlich eine eine Sicherheit haben,
vor allem international bisher nicht anerkannt, aber dann hoffentlich anerkannten Schiedsgericht eine Entschädigung für den entgangenen äh Gewinn holen kann. Das einer der großen kritisierten Punkte,
ähm das Freihandelsabkommens TTIP, dass man nämlich dann vor äh Schiedsstellen Möglichkeit hat, Schadensersatz für,
Zum Beispiel Verbraucherschutzmaßnahmen zu verlangen, die einem selbst das Geschäftsmodell verhageln, ja? Und da muss es nicht unbedingt darum gehen, dass es ein.
Ähm das ist ein direkt ein,
Atomausstieg beschlossen wird, sondern zum Beispiel auch Verschärfungen von Umweltmaßnahmen, die einzuhalten sind und die dann mit höheren Investitionen einhergehen oder so, alles Mögliche, was was man sich so äh was sich so ein äh
Parlament
zum Schutze der Bevölkerung und der Grundrechte vielleicht einfallen lassen könnte, dass unter Umständen mit den Interessen von Konzernen kollidieren könnte. Gibt's ja vereinzelte Fälle, wo das durchaus mal geschehen ist.
Datenschutz zum Beispiel.
Ne? Und auch da wäre dann also hier die Möglichkeit, man sollen diese Freihandelsabkommen dann eben strukturierte Möglichkeiten geben, dass sich Unternehmen gegen so etwas zur Wehr setzen können. Und das ist natürlich,
grundsätzlich schwierig, weil,
Hier einerseits unsere Demokratie irgendwie groß schreiben und andererseits den,
die Freiheit unseres Kapitals und da können wir natürlich jetzt nicht es zulassen, dass,
die Demokratie einfach die Freiheit des Kapitals beschränkt.
So, irgendwo ist ja auch mal Schluss. Und da von handelt eben dieses TTIP. Und gegen diesen Gedanken hat sich jetzt,
doch ein durchaus nennenswerter Protest formiert. Wo man sagt, okay, nee, wir möchten, dass,
wir die nationale Souveränität behalten, als als Land entscheiden zu können,
Nationen oder als Staat oder was auch immer man sich da äh zusammengetan hat, entscheiden zu können, folgendes sollen unsere Gesetze sein, folgende nicht
und uns ist scheißegal was das für euer Geschäftsmodell bedeutet. Klammer auf, so ist es auch heute nicht, ja? Wir wissen ja, dass Vattenfall irgendwie,
äh in Deutschland mehrere Länder oder dem Bund irgendwie verklagt hat auf Schadensersatz, all das in der Sendung von die wir mit
Katharina gemacht haben, LMP einhundertdreißig, da wurden diese Fälle nochmal im Detail behandelt.
Du sagst, es hat sich ein Widerstand gebildet gegen TTIP, mein Eindruck ist vor allem, dass ich sehr viele unterschiedliche Widerstände gebildet haben in den letzten Jahren,
gibt es, sagen wir mal, unsere netzpolitische äh Brille, ja, die insbesondere natürlich so Internet äh Stuff sieht
ähm dann gibt's halt, sagen wir mal so eine Agrar äh Brille, Bauern et cetera, die vor allem dann mit dieser ganzen äh äh Gendebatte, meinetwegen auch das raus. Ähm,
Also äh die Linie kommen ähm fallen mir noch zwei andere äh Vektoren ein,
die äh populär sind. Ich würde sagen, da sind so ein bisschen die die stärksten oder sagen wir mal, die generell und natürlich die die Grundrechts äh Kritik, die sich äh nicht nur, aber vor allem an diesen Sondergerichten aufhängt. Auch, wie ich finde,
vollkommen zurecht. Ähm,
Sodass also hier sehr lose bis überhaupt nicht miteinander verbundene gesellschaftliche Lager äh sich zumindest unter dem TTIP ist böse, wollen wir nicht, äh sind wir dagegen äh versammeln können.
Zuzüglich doch eines unangenehmen Teils, der auch äh sichtbar geworden ist auf dieser Demo, ähm dessen Bedeutung,
sehr schwierig einzuschätzen ist. Ähm ich weiß nicht genau, wie du das so benennen würdest, aber äh,
Es gibt auch so einen gewissen Bekloppten Anteil
der äh äh wunderbar in diesem TTIP-Prozess sich äh einreiht und das die mehr so oder so eine allgemeinen Amerika äh Feindlichkeit äh,
haben, glaube ich und so gegen TTIP sein ist, gegen Amerika sein
dann irgendwie äh so eine Bande von Putin verstehern und und sonstigen äh äh Lonis äh dabei, die halt auch äh da mitmarschieren.
Sie wollen das Gleiche, aber sie wollen, dass aus dem falschen Grund?
So
Ähm also ich habe ja gerade schon, um darauf anzuspielen, diesen Begriff nationale Souveränität verwendet, ja, sehr viel schöner beschreibt das, ähm Felix, äh Werdermann im Freitag, der also sagt,
Der Protest richtet sich,
gegen Sonderrechte für Konzerne, gegen die Einschränkungen des politischen Handlungsspielraums. Es geht darum, die Demokratie zu verteidigen.
Ähm jetzt könnte oder jetzt wird natürlich auch an vielen Ecken und Enden rumgetönt, dass,
Dieser gesamte Protest ähm,
Was weiß ich, so ein so Pegida, Empörungsindustrie, Anti-Amerikanismus, haste nicht gesehen, ne. Kapitalismuskritik, die das ist ja direkt hier antisemitisch und warte nicht alles gehört hast, ne? Ähm.
Die sicherlich auch irgendwo sichtbar sind, aber nicht unbedingt eine Mehrheit ausmachen.
Genau, wir haben, wir haben bei der, wir haben bei der ähm,
Es gibt da glaube ich verschiedene Mechanismen. Wir haben bei der Freiheit statt Angstdemo, ja. Sie in besten Zeiten hat sie, haben wir da auch äh durchaus ein paar Durchgeknallte gehabt.
Ja klar hier, die ganze Info war äh Kolumne et cetera.
Diese äh, die dann irgendwie Nine eleven nur sind, Insidejob und mit den mit den Chemtrails machen sie uns gefügig und so. Die hast du dann auch da stehen. Ähm.
Wenn wenn sich irgendwo, wenn sich irgendwo ein breiter Protest,
gegen irgendetwas entwickelt, völlig egal. Ja? Es also klare Grenze ist natürlich dann irgendwie bei Xenophobie oder sowas, ne. Da sagen wir mal ähm,
Es gäbe jetzt einen breiten,
Protest gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Stellen wir uns mal vor, es hätte eine aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen Gründen sich im Jahre zweitausendfünfzehn noch eine große Menge an Menschen gefunden, die richtig krass dagegen,
vorgeht. Meinst du ein ähm.
Lutz Bachmann, Pegida oder ein AfD,
Äh ich weiß gar nicht, wer da jetzt grad bei denen wechselt, dass er andauernd der Führer ist ja immer jemand anders.
Petri. Führerin.
Die Führerin und ähm so dann,
Meinst du, die hätten sich das entgehen lassen? Sich diesem breiten Protest mit anzuschließen und zu versuchen, diesem Protest ihre Färbung zu geben? Die Antwort lautet nein. Das sind,
Gruppierungen, die aus einer fundamental Opposition irgendwie sich bilden wollen und jede jede Art der Unzufriedenheit, die Menschen irgendwo äußern, versuchen werden, sich anzueignen.
Weil sie auch keine wirkliche politische Agenda haben, sondern eigentlich davon leben, gegen alles zu sein und Leute äh einfach in ihre Bewegung mit aufzunehmen, die erstmal die Fuß gegen irgendwas sind und am Ende ist es auch überhaupt nicht wichtig, wo gegen Hauptsache äh zu stimmen.
Hauptsache, die Bewegungen wächst so. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie gehst du als Demonstration damit um,
Ja, das war ja jetzt, das ist ja auch das, was jetzt unter den etwas informierteren Leuten äh diskutiert wird. Es gibt dann einmal durchaus äh wirklich diffamierende äh Artikel in den in den Zeitungen,
Und dann irgendwie so es als positive Artikel einem verkauft werden soll, da war nicht nur Pegida, ja ähm,
Das finde ich schon, finde ich schon echt,
relativ übel, wenn man sich überlegt, wer in diesem Demobündnis war und aus welcher Richtung dieser Protest tatsächlich kommt, ja? Von denjenigen, die diese Demonstration besucht haben, habe ich,
geschildert bekommen, dass dort,
vereinzelt mal irgendwie was weiß ich, ein kleiner Block von der ÖDP äh zu sehen war. Das ist irgendwie die ökologische, deutsche,
Ökologisch, demokratische Partei und das sind irgendwie so ein bisschen ähm das sind wohl so ein bisschen komische, ja, die irgendwie ähm.
Irgendwie eine leichte äh leichten, komischen Einschlag haben, ja, irgendwie so mit der äh wurde mir so geschildert. Ich kenne die noch nicht mal. Und da ich sie nicht kenne, ungefähr so groß war dann auch ihr Blog, äh mit dem sie dann da
rumgerannt sind, aber sie haben natürlich genau diese Technik angewandt, die ich gerade geschildert habe, äh schreiben natürlich zweihundertfünfzigtausend gegen ein paar dunkle Hinterzimmer in ihrer Demoberichterstattung. Da siehst du dann jetzt irgendwie so ein paar
Rentner mit so ein paar Fahnen, ja? Und die haben sich in diese Demo eingegliedert und und werben jetzt damit, ne, dass sie.
Zweihundertfünfzigtausend Leute äh mobilisiert haben, so ungefähr, ne. Und,
Wie gesagt, mir wurde geschildert, von auch von Leuten, die sich dann mal eine eine Stunde hingesetzt haben und sich diesen Demozug, der so vorbei lief am äh sowjetischen Ehren mal angeschaut haben, dass ihnen da jetzt keine großen,
Gruppen aufgefallen sind, die jetzt irgendwie einen starken, rechten Eindruck gemacht haben. Das heißt,
Als Erstes muss man wohl festhalten, dass diese Gruppen dort eine entschiedene Minderheit dargestellt haben.
Wie er auch bei der Freiheit statt Angst.
Wie auch bei der Freiheit statt Angstdemo. Ähm gleichzeitig kann man aber natürlich jetzt,
wenn es doch eine eine Minderheit war oder wenn es Minderheiten waren auf eurer vielfältigen äh Demonstration.
Wieso habt ihr die nicht ausgeschlossen?
Das ist eigentlich so die die Forderung, die jetzt so von von einigen Personen aufgestellt wird, ne? Man möge doch dann bitte äh diejenigen, die das,
das gleiche politische Ziel verfolgen, aber aus den falschen Gründen oder die in einem völlig
anderen Bereich, andere politische Ziele äh verfolgen. Von daher Demonstrationen ausschließen, weil sie ja nicht gesinnungsrein sind.
Und das finde ich eine sehr ähm unüberlegte,
Idee. Erstens, stellt sich mir die Frage nach der praktischen Umsetzung.
Ja, wie willst du denn das überhaupt? Wie willst du das machen? Kategorisieren.
Wie willst du das machen? Das Erste, was mir einfällt, was man da machen kann, ist natürlich zum Beispiel bei den Redebeiträgen ähm klare Stellung,
gegen rechts zu beziehen, was bei dieser Demonstration geschehen ist unter lautem Beifall,
Das andere wäre irgendwie so eine Art äh Demo Polizei, ja, also zu sagen, so nee, ähm.
Der Fahne nicht. Ich bin hier Ordner äh deine Forderung ist nicht oder deine Forderung ist zwar meine, aber auf dem falschen Plakat.
Ja, das fand ja auch statt, neulich zum Beispiel bei der Landesverrat-Demo, da kam ja dann auch äh so ein Trippchen äh Russland-Versteher, die dann äh das so ein bisschen für sich in äh,
versucht haben, sich da in die Kameras zu drücken et cetera und sind dann auch äh freundlich, aber bestimmt so ein bisschen ausgegrenzt worden. Also im Einzelnen.
Ausgegrenzt, aber sie waren trotzdem noch da.
Sie sollten zumindest mal ihre Fahnen da einrollen und so ein bisschen an die Seite gehen.
Also bei einer kleinen Demonstration kriegst du das ja vielleicht sogar noch hin, ne.
Bei einer großen ist das äh inpraktikabel. Wie willst du das auch überblicken? Also wo wo sollst du überhaupt die Mannstärke herbekommen, da jetzt äh bei zweihundertfünfzigtausend Leuten. Also das würde ja noch nicht mal die Polizei schaffen.
Richtig. Was mich jetzt also, was mich jetzt wirklich ärgert, was heißt ärgert? Ich rehe mich ja schon lange nicht mehr auf.
Aber doch. Aber was mich, was mich hier dann doch sehr wundert, ist, mit mit welcher Nachhaltigkeit ähm in mit wenigen Zeitungsartikeln, im Prinzip dieser dieser doch sehr breite Protest,
diskreditiert wird als, ja, die Zoo, ne, Pegida-Nazis, Pegida-Nazis sind gegen TTIP so ungefähr. Jetzt verkürzt da,
stellen, ne? Aber das ist durchaus eine eine ein Vorwurf, den sich dieser Protest jetzt ausgesetzt sieht. Und das finde ich, muss ich sagen, verheerend. Ich habe keine, ich meine, ich habe am wenigsten Verständnis für äh für diesen ganzen Pegida-Kram,
Ich habe aber auch ähm mindestens genauso wenig Verständnis dafür, dass man sich durch die Teilnahme,
vielleicht nicht,
deckungsgleich politisch aktiver Splittergruppen an einer Großdemonstration direkt die ganze Großdemonstration verhageln lassen soll.
Gut, ich meine, das ist einfach ein ein Werk
der politischen Auseinandersetzung, das sollte uns jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschen, dass natürlich alle Register gezogen werden an der Stelle und ähm das ist natürlich ein Problem und dem muss man sich äh entgegenstellen. Wie das ja auch getan wurde, wie du schon gesagt hast, ja, indem man das
bei den äh Reden äh klarmacht, dass man das vielleicht auch im Vorfeld schon klar macht. Schon im Rahmen der Ankündigung, da,
muss ich jetzt passen, weiß nicht, inwiefern es da schon äh entsprechende Stellungnahmen gegeben haben mag.
Weiß ich nicht, selbst wenn's die gegeben hat, wird das halt erstmal nichts verhindern, aber man kann zumindest schon mal klar sagen, wo man steht. Nur ist es natürlich jetzt gerade bei diesem Ding, wo ohnehin der Widerstand, wie ich ja schon eingangs betonte,
sich aus sehr vielen unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen Strömungen heraus
summiert. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass hier so eine kleine äh halbwegs scharfkantige äh äh gesellschaftliche Gruppe äh hingestellt hat und gesagt hat, wir müssen jetzt mal was dagegen machen, ja, wie die Freiheit statt Angst, Demo, die halt deutlich,
fokussierter ist es, auch ein breites Bündnis, aber es bewegt sich im Wesentlichen halt so im Rahmen der äh gesamten Netzpolitischen interessierten Gruppen. Nur hier ist es halt schon,
deutlich mehr als das. So wie er auch die Demonstration damals gegen den äh Irak,
Krieg in Deutschland, der ja auch äh,
hunderttausende an Leuten angezogen hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da die offiziellen Zahlen waren. Es war groß. Auch ja Leute aus allen Richtungen,
angezogen hat und da war sicherlich auch genug äh Idiotenvolk am Start. Habe jetzt keine gesehen, wüsste jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, was damals so die Agenda gewesen sein könnte, aber das hast du halt an der Stelle immer.
Sobald du, sobald sich, was weiß ich, drei Leute versammeln hast, eine Idioten dabei. Das ist, ich meine, das ist halt.
Ich hoffe, dass die Idioten gut im Allgemeinen noch etwas niedriger ist.
Ich habe jetzt extra drei gesagt, damit du dich nicht äh angesprochen fühlst. Aber.
Ich war ja nicht da.
Ähm,
nee, das du musst,
Also ich meine, das ist ein Problem durchaus und ich gehe ich würde aber jetzt auch der Gewerkschaft der Polizei, der IG Metall, Greenpeace, Foodwatch, Brot für die Welt, den Bund,
dem Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbund, äh dem WWF und so weiter nicht unterstellen wollen,
dass sie jetzt irgendwie mit den Rechten gemeinsame Sache machen, ja?
Warte mal, warte mal. Gewerkschaft der Polizei hat sich dem TTIP-Prozess angeschaut.
Die ist der die gehört zum Trägerkreis, der äh,
Der äh äh Stop TT CETA Demo am Samstag zehnten Oktober am Berlin Hauptbahnhof. Der der Trägerkreis ist drei,
sechs, neun, zwölf, sechsunddreißig Organisationen ungefähr, ach so, in der unteren Spalte sind ah, sind nicht in jeder Spalte gleich viel, aber okay.
Was, was, was hatte die Gddp da an Kritikpunkten?
Was weiß ich denn? Es geht doch einfach darum, dass da jeder.
Aber sie haben trotzdem nur auf hundertfünfzigtausend geschätzt. Siehst du mal.
So, also da sind, da sind einfach eine riesige Menge, dass ein breites Bündnis, ja,
der Verein mehr Demokratie, wirklich alles, ja? Da sind einfach alle einmal zusammen an einem äh an einem Strang gezogen,
dann konnte man den Aufruf noch mitunterzeichnen, sechzehntausend Personen haben dann nochmal den den Aufruf mitunterzeichnet, ja? Also das ist einfach ein breites Bündnis, kann man,
einfach mal sagen. Und wenn du ein so breites Bündnis hast, Digitalcourage auch dabei, ähm dann kriegst du das halt nicht hin,
da äh da Leute oder Gruppen von auszugrenzen.
Und ich würde sogar, ich finde, muss auch echt sagen, ich meine, es ist auch grenzwertig zu sagen, bei so einem Protest.
Du bist für das Gleiche, aber wir akzeptieren dich trotzdem nicht in unserem Kreise.
Ja, das kann, wie gesagt, ich meine, ich habe keine, kein Interesse, ähm,
mit irgendwelchen äh Pegida-Leuten zu marschieren. Ähm ich habe kein Interesse.
Deren deren und deren Kreis da auch nur in irgendeiner Form zu als Hebel zu benutzen, ja? Ich möchte die auch nicht dort haben,
Aber ich sehe auch ernsthaft keine gangbare Möglichkeit, ähm diese,
Menschen aus einem Protest fernzuhalten, aus einer Demonstration fern zu halten, weil sie, was weiß ich, aus den falschen Gründen das Gleiche wollen,
Es geht halt nicht, funktioniert nicht. Masse Demonstrationen sagst du bis gegen das und das kommen Leute hin, die dagegen sind und dann dann ist dann ist das so. Ähm,
Ist ärgerlich, aber ich sehe keinen äh keine realistische Möglichkeit, das zu verhindern. Und,
ähm umso ärgerlicher ist es, dass dass jetzt dieser Umstand doch genutzt wird, um ähm.
Um Menschen oder oder um diesen Protest zu diskreditieren. Mir fällt übrigens gerade ein, warum die GDP da war, weil die im Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbund ist und der Deutsche Gewerkschaftsbund war dagegen
Der deutsche äh Gewerkschaftsbund, der hat dann irgendwie IG Metall, Verdi und so weiter und die sind auch hier in dem Unterstützerkreis quasi ein Feld,
Deswegen ähm deswegen war die GDP äh gehört die GDP zum Unterstützerkreis. So schnell klärt sich das auf.
Ja, also Großdemo, schön ähm,
Ich denke, dass der Protest gegen TTIP durchaus einige entscheidende Argumente hat, allen voran eben dieses ähm Erhalten demokratischer Entscheidungsspielräume, die ja durch TTIP eindeutig,
eingeschränkt werden,
Beziehungsweise nicht eingeschränkt werden. Kannst ja immer noch dagegen entscheiden, musste ich halt nur nachher vor einem intransparenten Schiedsgericht äh hinter verschlossenen Türen für äh maßregeln lassen, was deine was deine
dein Staat demokratisch oder nicht demokratisch entschieden hat, ja?
Das ist durchaus, da da denke ich, kann man durchaus gegen protestieren. Ich finde das auch sehr unschön, dass es auch andere Menschen gibt. Äh mit denen ich bestimmte Meinungen nicht teile, die aber trotzdem an dieser Demo teilgenommen haben, im Gegensatz zu mir,
Aber ich habe eine Ausrede. Was ist deine?
Familie. Beibringen.
Aber ich sehe eben auch nicht wirklich eine realistische Szenario, wie man solche Leuten Leute fernhalten kann und aus den vielen äh Augenzeugen und Teilnehmerberichten, die ich mir angehört habe,
war dieses Problem auch ein,
Phänomen, ja, der größere Teil, der große mehrheitliche Teil dieser Demonstration war irgendwie bunt und hast du nicht gesehen und engagiert.
Das ist ein ist ärgerlich, dass es jetzt so dargestellt wird.
Ansonsten erhalte ich nämlich jetzt einfach bei jeder Demo äh ein Pegida-Schild hoch und sage hier.
Ja, genau.
Also das würde ich also das würde ich an Sigmar Gabriel jetzt machen. Würde jetzt einfach jeden jeden Protest, der mir nicht in die Wirtschaft passt, äh
Einfach ein paar Mann hinschicken mit irgendeiner dämlichen Fahne und einer Geotine oder so und sagen, komm mach mal ein paar, lassen wir ein paar schöne Bilder, damit wir die Idioten auch noch in den Griff kriegen
Da muss man sich halt auch über dieses Risiko muss man sich auch im Klaren sein.
So, kommen wir zu,
richtig äh äh wichtigen Ereignissen. Ähm,
weiteren wichtigen Ereignissen. Äh jetzt hätte ich mich hier fast in der Reihenfolge vertan, aber äh jetzt wollen wir über Exit sprechen. Wir hatten ja schon vor äh an zwei vor zwei Folgen glaube ich
Darüber äh berichtet, dass diese Aktion sich gegründet hat,
ausgehend von der Peng äh in Berlin und die haben ja dann in nach äh Bekanntwerden, nach äh Vorstellung äh,
des äh Programms, was ja so Geheimdienstler dazu motivieren soll, aus ihrem Job auszusteigen,
äh ordentlich äh Welle gemacht und diverse Aktionen gestartet,
einerseits halt überall Plakate aufgestellt, vor den,
und vor auch den Degger äh Komplex und das Ganze,
sogar noch weiter, dass sogar Drohnenflüge durchgeführt wurden, die Flyer abgeworfen haben, was ich schon ganz lustig fand.
Also es war eine, es war ein äh ferngesteuertes Flugzeug in Form einer Drohne. Wie heißen die nochmal? Es gibt es gibt zwei Drohnenmodelle, einmal Predator und dann oder zwei klassische und das andere ist.
Das war das andere oder was.
Aber wenn man dich mal was fragt, dann weißt du nämlich auch nicht.
Nö, freu nichts.
Ähm.
Bin jetzt so bei bei Technologie wirklich kein Experte, habe ich aber auch nie behaup.
Hätten wir den Frank fragen müssen. Der Frank ist ist Experte, aber ich gucke.
Ja, der kann da eine ganze Menge runter. Wollen wir jetzt noch anrufen?
Nee, ich ich gucke einfach mal kurz hier. Ich weiß ja, was das.
Ist das jetzt so wichtig, was das für eine eine Drohne war?
Ja, es war, es war halt keine Drohne. Es war ein ferngesteuertes Flugzeug.
Ja, aber welche welche ist es, wie es aussehen sollte sozusagen? Ich meine auch.
War ein, es war ein.
Auch eine Drohne ist ein ferngesteuertes Flugzeug.
Äh ja, aber es war halt leider nicht bewaffnet. Also es ist.
Mit Flyern bewaffnet.
Sie sind über den Deggerkomplex äh geflogen und haben dort äh Flugblätter abgeworfen. Du warst ja schon echt ganz cooles.
Ja, ist doch schön. Schon echt ganz cool ist. Ja.
Und ähm das finde ich schon eine eine ganz coole äh äh eine ganz coole Sache.
Gut, entscheidend ist ja, was kommt am Ende dabei? Es gab diese Woche eine Pressekonferenz, du warst da?
Ja, ich war, ich war, das war noch vor dem vor dem Flugblattabwurf. Ähm ich war bei der bei der Pressekonferenz,
Von Intel Exit und es war ähm, muss ich sagen, anders als ich erwartet hatte. Ja.
Zwar hatten sie erstmal ähm eine, da hatten sie zwei Gäste. Äh,
Einmal Frau Nigat, den Namen habe ich jetzt sicherlich falsch ausgesprochen. Nick hat Dart ähm aus Pakistan, die
über die Drohnenangriffe in Pakistan gesprochen hat und was was diese für das Zusammenleben und für die Angst bedeuten.
Ja, dass die Menschen Angst vorm Himmel haben, ja, hat einen sehr eindrücklichen Appell äh geäußert an die Bundesregierung, eben diese,
diese Kriegsführung, diese Angriffe nicht weiter äh zu unterstützen,
und dann äh mietet Özdemir von der Initiative Keupstraße, Keupstraße wir erinnern uns, da gab es, dass äh Nagelbombenattentat des NSU, ja? Wie sich da nachher herausstellte, ähm denn.
Ähm was,
Zunächst dann längere Zeit äh vermutet wurde, war eben, dass es ja irgendwie diese Personen ähm,
selber waren, die diesen Anschlag verübt haben, denn diese Personen, mit diese Person, meine ich, die Bewohner des Viertels, ist eine ähm,
Straße in Köln Mühlheim, ähm wo es sehr viele äh türkische Geschäfte gibt.
Und die Ermittler, die sich diesem, diesem Nagelbombenangriff auf diese Straße äh genähert haben, äh sind offenbar sehr klar mit der, mit der Hypothese daran gegangen, dass es da sich ja irgendwie um ähm
Bandenkriminalität handeln muss, weil die die Ausländer, die da wohnen, die sind ja sowieso alle kriminell und ist ja kein Wunder, äh wenn die dann irgendwann zu Bomben greifen, ja, also das ist ja sowieso bei bei den,
offenbar allen NSU Morden und Anschlägen die Hypothese gewesen, dass man meinte, man wäre da jetzt auf einem ganz auf einer ganz heißen,
Spur,
Was, was, was äh die kriminellen Ausländerbanden angeht, äh die sich die ganze Zeit gegenseitig abknallen, ne? Am Ende hat sich rausgestellt, waren einfach Nazis, die durchs Land gefahren sind und und einfach wahllos Menschen getötet haben. Eben auch dieses Bombenantentat,
verrichtet haben. Und er hat dann mal so, was ich sehr interessant fand, aus aus der aus der Perspektive der Bewohner, geschildert, weißt du, wie da irgendwie die,
die Ermittler mit dieser Hypothese ankommen, dann irgendwie sagen, sag, was, sag, was für eine Rückraum du verheimlichst doch, was hier, ne? Und dann haben sie, äh, haben die Bewohner halt irgendwann oder die Anwohner, ne? Auch die Betroffenen natürlich.
Mit euch, brauchen wir uns nicht zu unterhalten,
Ihr unterstellt uns, dass wir das fanden. Wir sind hier die Opfer so. Was dann von den Ermittlern wiederum ausgelegt wurde als ja, die Mauern, sie hüllen eine Mauer des Schweigens und das Attentat. So, ne? Äh.
Und der also mal so diesen äh diesen äh strukturellen Rassismus äh,
in der Gesellschaft und in den Ermittlungen in diesem, in diesem Bereich dargestellt haben. Da ist hat's natürlich auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz äh war da von seinen Schilderungen äh betroffen,
Beides, beides sehr, sehr eindrücklich, aber man hat ja dann erstmal auch gedacht, okay, warum äh warum das jetzt hier bei Intel Exit, ne, man hätte ja eher erwartet, dass sie etwas von ihren ähm Erfolgen,
kundtun oder von ihren Aktionen. Äh das war da aber erstmal weniger der Fall in diesem äh bei dieser Pressekonferenz.
Erst später haben sie dann also gesagt, dass sich ähm zwei Personen schon bei ihnen gemeldet haben, die ähm,
glaubhaft, äh glaubhaft sind, ja, es haben sich natürlich sehr viele gemeldet, ne? Also kannst du dir vorstellen, dass dir meldet euch bei uns, wenn ihr das ein Geheimnis,
aussteigen wollt, dann hast du sofort Bernd da, der dann sagt so ne? Sag äh ist ja klar, aber jetzt also zwei bei denen, die also ihre äh Plausibilitätsprüfung und so dann irgendwie und jetzt in längeren Gesprächen sind und im Detail und so und,
den also dann,
psychologischer Rat und rechtlicher Rat vermittelt wird. Das ist also das, was diese Initiative ähm bietet. Und gleichzeitig.
Wurde auch betont, dass es eben nicht darum geht, nicht primär darum geht, den den nächsten AdWord snoaden,
unbedingt dort zu kreieren.
Also es geht nicht darum Leaks zu erzeugen.
Nicht primär.
Nicht primär, man hätte nichts dagegen, aber darum geht's erstmal nicht.
Genau. Es geht erst mal darum, die Menschen äh da rauszuholen.
Da kann man sich auch dieses schöne Formular zusammenklicken mit so vorformulierten Argumenten et cetera. Dann kriegt man etwas ähm Überarbeitungswürdig formatiertes äh äh PDF. So, da kann man dann schon mal äh vielleicht mit anfangen. Vielleicht werden,
transportieren wird, weil du äh erzeugen. Wie auch immer, ähm ja, das.
Bin mir immer noch nicht so ganz so sicher, was am Ende äh bei dieser,
ähm herauskommen soll, sollte es tatsächlich ähm dazu führen, dass verschiedene Leute über ihre Situation weiter nachdenken, als es ohnehin schon getan haben und äh gegebenenfalls hier auch
tatsächlich hilfskräftige Hilfe angeboten äh bekommen, dann hat sich das schon gelohnt.
Genau, also wenn man, wenn man da jetzt ein, wenn man da jetzt einzelne Personen rauskriegt, ja, und dadurch die Geheimdienste,
schwächt, dann ist das doch eine ist das auch keine äh keine schlechte Sache, ja? Auch äh.
Wenn man das, also ich finde, das ist so eine Exit-Kampagne gibt, du hast das in der vorletzten Sendung so auch,
Angesprochen. Ähm ne, von den von den Rechten gibt's das ja auch. Die der grade äh so deutsche Behörden haben wir dann auch so exit, ne. Wir Straftäter liegen's und so, Aussteigerprogramme und so, ne? Und
da finden wir es ja völlig normal, also wir wir finden das als Gesellschaft völlig normal, dass es Aussteigerprogramme gibt,
die sich an Linke richten, ja,
von Christina Schröder, glaube ich, damals ins Rennen geführt oder so. Und es gibt Aussteigerprogramme, die sich an rechte Gruppierungen richten. Warum soll es dann kein Aussteigerprogramm geben, was sich an äh Geheimdienstmitarbeiter richtet? Ich mein,
Insgesamt Netto betrachtet hat wahrscheinlich der der Anhänger einer der durchschnittliche Anhänger einer rechten Gruppierung,
Und der durchschnittliche Anhänger einer linken Gruppierung der Demokratie weniger Schaden zugefügt, als der durchschnittliche Mitarbeiter eines Geheimdienstes.
Gewagt These. Durchschnittliche Mitarbeiter eines Geheimdienstes.
Der durchschnittliche Mitarbeiter eines Geheimdienstes ähm hat These,
Der durchschnittliche Mitarbeiter eines Geheimnisses hatte Demokratie mehr Schaden zugefügt als der durchschnittliche Anhänger einer äh Rechten oder einer linken Gruppierung,
weil die meisten Gruppierungen, ne, vor allem diejenigen, äh bei denen um aus äh stieg gebuhlt wird, haben ja keinerlei politischen Einfluss,
Ich meine, die haben, da sind halt dann manchmal Terrorgruppen drunter, ja. Ja, ne, NSU oder so, das wäre gut gewesen, wenn da mal.
Parteien wie NPD, also da würde ich das jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres unterschreiben. Das finde ich jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Haben die haben die haben hat die NPD irgendwo wirklich demokratischen Einfluss? Also.
Sitzenden Parlamenten.
Ja, aber könnt ihr Einfluss ausüben.
Sie können dadurch Einfluss üben, dass sie natürlich dadurch, dass sie im staatlichen System aufgehoben sind und äh auch finanziert werden,
natürlich ganz andere Möglichkeiten haben, ihren Unsinn äh zu verbreiten, als wenn das nicht der Fall wäre, von daher äh würde ich jetzt nicht grundsätzlich das so unter äh.
Unsinn Unsinn verbreiten, Klammer ich und von der Demokratie schaden aus.
Ich würde das jetzt so nicht sagen.
Okay, aber sagen wir mal so, wenn wir Aussteigerprogramme für für.
Der Vergleich bringt uns jetzt nicht groß weiter.
Wenn wir, wenn wir Aussteigerprogramme für demokratiefeindliche Gruppen anbieten, dann können wir, dann ist es durchaus gerechtfertigt, das auch für äh,
Für den Verfassungsschutz und und Geheimdienste.
Bin ich dann äh mit ja, ja.
Okay, wunderbar, dann hat die Kurve ja noch gekriegt.
Insofern finde ich das gut, dass es das gibt und vor allem darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, dass die die Existenz solcher Aussteigerprogramme ein äh ein substantiellen Anteil an der Echtung von diesen Gruppen haben,
Und insofern finde ich das äh auch unter diesem, unter diesem, unter diesen Gesichtspunkten keine schlechte Idee, dieses äh Intel Exit zu machen. Und sie fahren also, ne, irgendwie,
Bei Lokhit Marten durch die Gegend mit ihren Aussteiger äh Trucks beim verteilen sie Flyer, beim Bundesnachrichtendienst,
Informationsbroschüren, dann haben sie beim ähm beim Verfassungsschutz äh die Verfassung an die Tür geklebt und haben sich angeguckt, wie die wieder abgekratzt wird.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin? So öffentlich die Verfassung ausgehangen wird. Am Ende liest sich das noch einer durch.
Gleichzeitig noch mit dran eben ein offenbar solides Programm mit juristischer und psychologischer Beratung für diejenigen, äh die da wirklich raus wollen.
Und natürlich, wie das immer so ist, ähm Finanzbedarf, äh im Moment haben fehlen den ungefähr äh neuntausend Euro, wir haben verlinkt, wie man für intel Exit spenden kann.
Jo, ähm wollen wir weitermachen? Gut.
Jetzt kommt ein Thema, also jetzt wird die Sendung auf jeden Fall die zwei Stunden Marke schlagen, weil es geht um Breitbandausbau und da kriegen wir den Tim jetzt, der sitzt schon hier mit den Krallen in im Tisch.
Schwillt der Kamm. Weil die zwei Stunden schon so nah dran. Oh ja, oh Gott.
Das wird, das ist jetzt hier, da gibt's ein, also wir erinnern uns, wir kriegen ja, ne, bis ich weiß noch nicht mal, wann. Kriegen wir flächendeckend fünfzig Mbit.
In mehreren Jahren irgendwann vielleicht unter Umständen vielleicht.
Im Moment sieht's aber nicht danach aus, da gibt's jetzt einen Bericht des Bundesrechnungshofs, ja, Verkehrsminister Dobrindt äh hat ja zweitausenddreizehn.
Weitere Bereiche dazu bekommen äh und diese Bereiche nennt er digitale Gesellschaft und die gliedern sich in Breitbandförderung,
Netzallianz und strategische Aspekte der digitalen Infrastruktur und Gesellschaft,
Ja? Also man sieht da, wo da mal nicht von irgendwie McKinsey beraten, weil die sind eben nicht äh mies, sondern einfach irgendwie dahin gewürfelte Bereiche, wo unter wo man sich unter keinem was vorstellen kann,
und äh wo man auch also Breitbandförderung kann man sich noch was drunter vorstellen, Netzallianz wird schon schwieriger
wie das jetzt wiederum abtrennbar ist, ne? Äh zu strategischer Aspekte der digitalen Infrastruktur und Gesellschaft ist ist offen, ist ist wirklich unklar, ja? Und genau das hat auch der Bundesrechnungshof festgestellt, der nämlich sagt,
Die hat überhaupt gar keine Aufgabenanalyse äh stattgefunden, ähm dass man sich mal überlegt hatte, hätte, was sind denn die zu erledigenden Aufgaben,
Und wie lassen sich diese Aufgabe in Bereiche gliedern, sodass diese Bereiche auch von vorneherein,
Ordentliche, organisatorische Strukturen aufbauen, ja?
Ist sehr interessant, dass es ausgerechnet vom Bundesgerichtshof äh Entschuldigung, Bundesrechnungs äh.
Bundesrechnungshof. Nee, der macht ja genau solche Prüfungen. Der soll ja, der der guckt sich ja an.
Wo geht das Geld hin? Et cetera. Trotzdem finde ich die Analyse natürlich sehr interessant, dass sie sozusagen fünf also normalerweise dreht es sich ja dann immer um so,
Geldverschwendung. Ihr habt da eine Brücke gebaut, das war viel zu teuer et cetera und äh ne, so ist so die Richtung. Klar, das hat hier so einen ähnlichen Aspekt, aber dass sie dann in der Analyse wirklich sagen, ja äh
also dass sie in ihrer Analyse sagen, ihr hättet überhaupt mal erstmal eine machen sollen, weil ganz offensichtlich habt ihr ja keine gemacht
dass es äh schon wirklich eine ziemlich bemerkenswerte Feststellung.
Sie, sie bemerken dann noch, dass er ja irgendwie erst fünfundzwanzig und dann irgendwie ein paar Wochen später Neunundvierzig Planstellen haben wollte. Also, ich meine,
Doppelung des Personalbedarfs, ja? Beide Zahlen aber ohne jegliche,
sinnvolle Begründung äh in den Raum gestellt hat, ne? Ich meine, wer sich mal anschauen will, wie solche Zahlen offenbar sinnvoll begründet, äh veröffentlicht werden sollen, kann sich ja diese,
Äh äh Landesverrat liegt's vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz anschauen. Da steht ja dann drin, ne, wie so wie wo man dann irgendwie,
Darf so und so viel äh Stellenbedarf so und so, ne. Sowas hätten die da wohl erwartet. Es geht noch weiter. Ähm,
Sagt er, na ja, für den Breitbandausbau habt ihr hier offensichtlich einfach mal ein paar Milliarden über den Daumen geschätzt, ohne irgendeine Analyse des tatsächlichen Finanzbedarfs vorzunehmen.
Also gehst einfach hin ja wir machen Breitbandauswahl, wir brauchen flächendeckend fünfzig M-Bit,
sechs Milliarden oder was auch immer die Zahl war, die da äh eine Rolle gespielt hat, ja. Ähm das heißt, es wurde überhaupt gar kein Bedarf analysiert, sondern einfach irgendeine Zahl in den Raum gestellt, dass erinnert so ein bisschen an alles eigentlich an unseren Flughafen hier in Berlin, ne?
Auch einfach so wie auch kostet, ungefähr so und so viel, ja, vielleicht oh ja, so hätten wir planen müssen, ja.
Und.
Dann, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt was, da kommt Zucker schon für dich, Tim. Äh es wird bemängelt, dass nicht analysiert wurde, ob innovative oder seit Jahren etablierte Übertragungstechniken gefördert werden sollen. Denn,
fünfzig MIT als Ziel ist klar, fünfzig MB ist so das, was du mit Kupfer irgendwie noch ganz gut hinkriegst. Das kannst du versprechen, ne?
Vor allem das, was ich schon seit Jahren habe.
Ja, was du seit Jahren hast, ja. Okay, bevor du gleich in deinen Breitband-Rand kommst, äh war ich noch kurze, hä? Und es wird also vom vom Bundesrechnungshof wird im Prinzip diese Kupferliebe kritisiert, ne, dass sie sagen,
Ähm.
Absehbar, dass man das in ein paar Jahren wieder komplett übern Haufen werfen,
um die nächsten Ziele zu erreichen? Was investiert ihr jetzt hier in das Zeug? Finde ich auch sehr bemerkenswert, dass sie überhaupt so einen tiefen Blick dort äh wagen.
Sehr analytisch äh sozusagen ins also sehr viel mehr analytisch ins Thema reingeht, als es das Verkehrsministerium selber äh so macht. Aber.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, die hören Logbuch Netzpolitik, aber wahrscheinlich könnte ich sagen, die hören irgendeinen deiner Podcasts, weil,
Das Thema wurde, glaube ich, in allen schon behandelt.
Ja, sicherlich, auf auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise. Und ich meine, letzten Endes muss man da noch nicht mal Podcast zu hören. Ich denke, wenn man sich einfach mit dieser Thematik auch nur ansatzweise mal beschäftigt und
Das ist sicherlich im Verkehrsministerium, wo man sich wahrscheinlich bisher mehr über Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung und äh Tilung von äh
Versiegelung von Bodenflächen Gedanken gemacht hat,
nicht so überraschend. Ich meine, diese ganze drei Fragezeichen-Nummer hatten wir ja nun auch äh schon mehrfach diskutiert, also dieser Warnwitz, dass eben diese ganze Internet äh äh Initiative der Bundesregierung
vorne rein schon mal so auf drei oder vielleicht sogar vier verschiedene Ressource ausgebreitet wurde, ohne klare Zuständigkeitsbereiche zu haben, beziehungsweise dadurch auch noch herbei
beschworen hat, dass es eigentlich auch vollkommene Überlappungen gibt. Jeder wollte irgendwie für das Internet zuständig sein. Herr Gabriel, Herr Dobrindt, äh und
das äh wer war noch gleich der Dritte, das Innenministerium? Das ist natürlich vollkommen absurd.
Das zeigt sich natürlich jetzt hier in dieser Analyse des Bundesrechnungshofes auf wunderbare Art und Weise.
Ja
Ja, das ist äh äh ohnehin, also dieser Bericht hat ja auch noch ein paar andere Sachen aufgedeckt, da gibt's ja dann auch noch irgendwie so ein Planungsbüro, so,
Externes, was dann irgendwie auch noch äh äh einen Auftrag bekommen hat, also auf.
Sie haben das jetzt, sie haben das jetzt an ein, an einen Planungsbüro übergeben.
Das heißt, sie waren selber gar nicht in der Lage, das zu tun.
Das ist ja schon offenkundig und dann haben sie den Arbeitsauftrag dieses Planungsbüros nach und nach immer weiter erweitert, ja? Und jetzt sagt der ähm Rechnungshof,
wenn ihr einen Auftrag von diesem Ausmaß aus übergebt, vergibt, dann müsst ihr den EU-weit ausschreiben.
Und,
das bringt natürlich dann nochmal eine weitere Verzögerung, wenn Sie das jetzt tun. Ja, also ab einer gewissen am einen gewissen Auftragsvolumen kannst du nicht einfach äh den Auftragnehmer deiner Wahl,
bestellen,
sondern du musst es EU-weit ausschreiben. Dann kannst du dann und dann bietet halt, was weiß ich, ein britisches Unternehmen plötzlich äh ähm,
Sehr günstig auf das Konzept vom deutschen Breitbandausbau. Also es ist äh es ist einfach nur in diesem Bericht steht, glaube ich, jetzt drin,
Warum sich der ganze Scheiß um mindestens drei, vier Jahre verzögert? Ja und da wird jetzt schon bemängelt, dass egal, welche Entscheidung da getroffen wird, alles, was bisher gesagt wurde, totaler Scheiß ist.
Ja und vor allem halten sie auch selber schon äh relativ klar fest, was ich auch bemerkenswert finde für einen Rechnungshof, ja, also dessen primäre,
Ausrichtung ja sozusagen das Geld ist dass sie feststellen dass es ja
auf innovative und Zukunftstechnologien gesetzt werden sollte und das ist doch äh kein Weg, einen Glasfaserausbau vorbeiführen würde. Ich meine, da muss man halt nicht weit gucken. Ja, da schaut man sich zum Beispiel mal,
Rest der Welt an. So, irgendwo, ja äh und schon äh äh kommt man im Prinzip genau da hin und ähm dass das alles so schwer zu verstehen ist für die Bundesregierung, ehrlich gesagt, mich,
das auch so ein bisschen,
irre im Kopf. Also ich meine, gut, jetzt war alles Neuland, ja? Bis vor Kurzem, so, aber das kann doch jetzt nicht so schwer zu verstehen sein, dass man hier nicht klein denken kann.
Und äh das findet irgendwie nicht statt. Das das ist äh einfach komplett abwesend und ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, also ja. Wie gesagt, steht jetzt auch da drin.
Und ich finde auch das Verkehrsministerium,
ist einfach, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was was die da damit zu tun haben, ja? Also letzten Endes, was wir brauchen, ist wahrscheinlich eine Art Internetministerium, auch wenn ich mir, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so sicher bin, ob ich mir das wirklich wünschen soll,
weißt du? Weil wenn man dann erstmal da eins hat, guckt das alles so gut ist, aber klar, ne?
Hätte man jetzt sozusagen eine Regierung gewählt, mit der wir äh problemlos äh morgens aufstehen äh können ohne gleich Schweißausbrüche zu bekommen, äh dann wäre so ein Internetmission bestimmt äh ein ganz sinnvolles Instrument
ist einem gelingt, dort die Kompetenzen, die bundesrechtlichen Kompetenzen zu bündeln, die eben diesen Ausbau auch wirklich voranbringen
also was da dem einzelnen dazugehört, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Sicherlich müsste man auch dem Verkehrsministerium ähm das ein oder andere wegnehmen oder zumindest da sehr klare äh Kanäle schaffen, um ebenso äh Wegerechtsplanung et cetera da in die Hand zu nehmen. Das war ja wahrscheinlich die Hauptmotivation.
Hinter dieser Vergabe, was äh auch nachvollziehbar ist, trotz alledem
bedarf es eben einfach weiterer Kompetenzen, dass hier diese Kompetenz nicht vorhanden ist, zeigt allein schon diese nachträgliche Verdopplung, ach so schwierig ist das. Naja dann dann kommt man ja nicht.
Es ist ja es ist eine.
Also bei äh Breitband äh ihr da draußen.
Wurde verschoben.
Wenn ihr äh wenn ihr noch auf euren schnellen Anschluss wartet, legt euch einfach noch mal ein Kissen und dann hintern, es könnte noch etwas dauern.
ER Reitband.
Genau. In Breitband.
Ja, schlimm.
Breitbandausbau.
Ja, so ist das.
Gut. Aber kommen wir doch wieder zurück zu unseren Lieblingsthemen Geheimdiensten. Warum haben wir das eigentlich in dieser Reihenfolge gemacht? Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Was weiß ich, könnt ihr mal auch mal ein bisschen mischen.
Ist mal gut wieder auf dieselbe Geschichte zurückzukommen. Ja Herr Maaßen. Herr Maaßen, unser also Lieblingsbeamter.
Herr Maaßen hat sich jetzt also es gibt einen sehr schönen äh sehr schönen Artikel von Kai Biermann, Aufzeit Online, in dem er sagt äh der Whistleblower vom Amt ist ja unser Herr Maaßen, denn.
Chef vom Verfassungsschutz.
Im im Juli zweitausenddreizehn gab es ein ähm Bericht bei Spiegel Online,
Bezug zu Snowden, Dokumenten, wo drin steht, das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz nutzt. Ex-Kiscor.
Was nicht drin stand ist, wie, wo, seit wann, ja, in welchem Ausmaß? Es stand einfach nur drin, Verfassungsschutz nutzt Ex-Hießrohr.
Und.
Begründet war das mit das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, habe den Einsatz von Exkiescore nicht erläutern wollen,
Einen Tag später, ne, am einundzwanzigsten Juni zweitausenddreizehn wurde dann in der Bild am Sonntag ein sehr viel ausführlicher Text äh über Exki-Score veröffentlicht,
Und darin hieß es, nach Informationen vom Bild am Sonntag, analysiert der Verfassungsschutz mithilfe von Ex-Keescore testweise bereits vorhandene Daten aus der Telekommunikationsüberwachung nach dem G zehn Gesetz.
So, das war zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht bekannt.
Es stand auch nicht, es stand auch nicht in den ähm in den äh Dokumenten. Das heißt, Maaßen hat,
Ähm den Stand dieses Projektes verraten.
Seine Mutmaßung oder ist das irgendwie beste.
Nee, das ist äh das ist äh bestätigt, dass er das war.
Oh.
Er verteidigt sich mit äh na, er hätte den,
den Falschdarstellungen da irgendwie widersprechen wollen, ne? Oder dass das ein äh einsortieren,
wollen. Was natürlich genau dermaßen, der es für einen Riesenskandal halt hielt, dass Vernetzpolitik veröffentlicht wurden.
Die Rückschuss auf den aktuellen Stand derer Kapazitäten und Techniken zulassen, ja? Also er, er sagt, äh.
Er habe Missverständliche, er habe missverständlichen Formulierungen proaktiv entgegentreten wollen. Ja, das könnte man natürlich, kann andere Meister ja auch sagen. Ich wollte missverständigen äh,
Formulierung proaktiv entgegentreten, indem ich einfach mal die Originaldokumente veröffentliche, damit klar ist, äh worüber wir hier reden.
Ja, aber hier wird halt mit zweierlei Maßen gemessen. Wenn's vom Amt her äh getan wird, dann ist halt alles supi. Ne.
Oder vielleicht hat es ja auch irgendwelche steuerrechtlichen Gründe, dann ist das ja demnächst kein Problem,
Ja. Ähm ja.
Also er, er betont ja immer, ne, man kann nicht einfach äh geheime Dinge herausposaunen, auch nicht, wenn's einem, wenn's opportun ist oder sonst was. Äh die Bundesregierung ähm,
ne
Ist hier in Gefahr oder so, ne? Geheimhaltung ist nicht irgendwie etwas, womit man nach Spaß umgehen kann, aber Caipiermann hat hier aufgedeckt, dass er's äh,
Sehr klar getan hat.
Weiterhin. Ja.
Weiterhin weiterhin hat äh Maaßen äh gibt's ja noch einen weiteren Fall, der jetzt gerade oder ein weiteres Thema, was da gerade diskutiert wird, da ist ja immer noch die Ermittlung wegen Landesverrat gegen Andre und Markus. Er will ja jetzt keiner gewesen sein,
Keiner will's gewesen sein, ne. Ähm und äh es gibt also ein ein Interview von,
mit mit Hans-Georg Maaßen mit einem ihm offenbar sehr wohlgesinnten Journalisten ähm,
wo Maßnahmen betont, die Strafanzeigen meiner Behörde waren gegen unbekannt erstattet worden. Zielrichtungen waren insofern,
waren insoweit nicht Journalisten gewesen. Das möchte ich an dieser Stelle noch einmal betonen. Mir geht es darum, Lex zu stopfen. Mir geht es auch darum, die Personen, die Informationen in die Öffentlichkeit geben, dass diese Person dafür auch
bestraft werden und ich denke, dass es nicht nur legitim und ich empfinde das auch als eine Verpflichtung, dies zu tun, weil meine Aufgabe, wie ich's sagte,
auch darin besteht, Geheimhaltungsbedürftige Unterlagen geheim zu halten, sagte er im im Interview, ja. Mindestens in.
Waren diese anderen Informationen jetzt dann doch nicht mehr so bedürftig.
Natürlich waren die geheim. Aber nicht mehr bedürftig.
Ich meine, was das auch sehr schön zeigt, sollte man schon nochmal rausstellen. Äh uns mag das ein gewisser Hinsicht,
keine besondere Nachricht mehr äh enthalten, aber erstens, also abgesehen jetzt von dieser offensichtlichen Doppel äh Züngigkeit, was was äh das Verhalten an sich betrifft, aber,
Einerseits zeigt es eben sehr schön, wie geheime Informationen, also sagen wir mal,
das äh Herrschaftswissen über einen gewissen Sachverhalt.
Auch strategisch genutzt werden kann.
Ohne Strafe sozusagen auch nur von denen, die dieses Wissen vorhalten und außerdem,
dass das eben sehr wohl auch umfasst gezielte Medien anzusprechen, die eine gewisse, wie soll ich sagen.
Staatstreue aufweisen. Weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt besser formulieren kann, ja?
Zum Zwecke ähm ja einer öffentlichen Darstellung ohne genaue Quellen. Das heißt, da wird halt einfach mal eine Information,
lanciert, äh damit sie in der Öffentlichkeit steht, damit sie einen gewissen Eindruck hinterlässt,
Das ist ja im Prinzip das, was was hier äh geschehen ist. Wie gesagt, mag uns nicht sonderlich
vorkommen, finde es trotzdem mal sehr schön, dass ich das jetzt hier auch mal so ganz klar darstellt.
Ähm und man muss sich halt eben fragen, ja, was ist mit anderen Berichten, mit anderen äh entsprechenden äh Gefärbten ähm Informationen
die man eben aus bestimmten Quellen wahrnimmt,
An der Stelle finde ich das eben auch sehr schön mit Originaldokumenten äh zu arbeiten, wie es Netzpolitik org auch gemacht hat, weil er es zumindest mal klar, wo diese Informationen.
Auf jeden Fall wird diese dieses Zitat, was ich grade da zitiert habe, oder die Aussage, die ich gerade zitiert habe, äh nochmal in in einem interessanten Licht stehen ähm,
weil erstens er,
Offenbar selber Geheimnisse verrät, ja. Ähm wenn es ihm politisch opportun scheint und andererseits bezieht macht er daran eine Aussage über das,
dass seine seine Strafanzeigen ja ungerichtet gewesen seien. Und es gibt ja noch dieses ähm.
Dieses Gutachten des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz bezüglich der äh Geheimhaltung bezüglich des der geheim,
Haltung, Stufe der Dokumente und der Schädigung der Bundesrepublik. Ja, äh also das, worauf sich die das Gutachten, worauf sich die Anzeige oder das Ermittlungsverfahren begründet hat, wozu ähm,
Der Generalbundesanwalt noch ein zweites haben wollte, von einem, von einer weniger abhängigen Stelle. Und genau dieses Gutachten,
Ist ja auch heute noch unter Verschluss. Das ist ja geheim ja als die Geheimdokumente selbst.
Noch geheimer.
Ja, denn äh da da das ist einfach, selbst im Rahmen der Akteneinsicht nicht
zu Markus und Andre übergegangen. Und da wird sich jetzt zeigen ob in diesem Gutachten der Wink in Richtung Markus und Andre drin ist,
dann kann sich Maaßen nämlich nicht mehr rauswickeln aus der Nummer, dass er ja ja, ich habe ja nur äh eine ich wollte ja nur den Geheimnisverrat stoppen,
Das wird mal interessant zu sehen, äh wenn dieses Gutachten dann äh mal irgendwann geleakt wurde. Dann können wir da mal reinschauen.
Ähm.
Damit sind wir am Ende der Neuigkeiten.
Genau, der richtigen Neuigkeiten. Jetzt gibt's aber noch einen Nachtrag.
Ja, es gibt noch was Wichtiges.
Mhm.
Und zwar haben wir beim Camp schon die Initiative vorgestellt, also,
Was heißt, wie haben die vorgestellt? Die haben sich selber vorgestellt und ähm das ist also ein,
Verein, der sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, die Unterkünfte für,
Geflüchtete mit Selbstverwalteten Internetcafes auszustatten,
ich denke, dass wer da sich ein bisschen zu dem Thema ein bisschen was gelesen hat, weiß, dass,
bis dahin. In den meisten Unterkunft für Geflüchtete einfach gar keine Internetanschlüsse gibt.
Und ähm dass das natürlich auch ein Problem ist, ja? Also die wollen sich informieren, äh die wollen unter Umständen in Kontakt mit äh ihrer Familie treten,
Ähm insbesondere brauchen sie äh relativ viele Informationen, was also wie stellt man überhaupt den Antrag, ne, worauf muss man achten und so. Also,
ich will mich jetzt nicht lange damit aufhalten zu erklären, warum die Menschen Internet brauchen.
Und ähm Refugees impression ist also eine,
Ein Verein von Geflüchteten für Geflüchtete, die,
Internetcafés einrichten und dabei besonderen Wert darauf legen, dass diese Internetcafés selbst verwaltet sind. Und nicht einfach irgendwie
ein Internetanschluss da ist, auf dem irgendwie ein riesiger Filter hängt oder sonst was, ne? Oder von von irgendjemandem bereitgestellt wird und dann irgendwie ein Schild dransteht so von von acht bis neun hier Internet oder so und,
ähm also selbstverwaltete Internetcafes mit Kursen,
und Rechnern bereitgestellt werden. Ähm betonen auch, dass es ihnen zum Beispiel nicht unbedingt darum geht, dass es da irgendwie, dass das ganze Ding unter WLAN steht, sondern dass sie auch das auch als Begegnungsstätte haben möchten, ja?
Und dort irgendwie Menschen äh.
Die dort wohnen, ja auch in den in der Nutzung von Computern, Schulen, wenn sie eine derartige Schulung denn wünschen. Und ähm,
der Förderverein Freie Netze, der Chaos, Computerclub und die der Verein digitale Gesellschaft, unterstützen Refugees im nun dabei, ähm Gelder zu sammeln für,
Ihr, Ihre Arbeit und Ihr Fortbestehen. Und äh das ist etwas, was ich äh sehr wichtig finde,
und deshalb möchte ich äh hier auch dazu aufrufen,
dort zu spenden. Die Spendenkampagne ist schon ganz gut angelaufen. So, ist jetzt bei ähm achtunddreißig Prozent, glaube ich, gerade, mit ungefähr zweihundert äh Spenden,
Das heißt noch, wenn wir jetzt nochmal zweihundert Leute mobilisiert bekommen, dann ist dieses Ding gewuppt und dann kann da eine eine Initiative, die sage ich mal, das Kriterium sustainability erfüllt, einfach mal äh.
Gefördert werden. Dazu möchte ich aufrufen. Und wer sich weiter darüber informieren möchte, dem ist,
ähm Schwantaler, Episode sechsundvierzig empfohlen, ähm wo,
Ein Vertreter der Support-Gruppe ähm
nochmal genauer die Motive und die Hintergründe zu Refugees im Incipation erklärt. Das war eine sehr schöne Episode von Schwantaler, weil mir das Thema ja auch am Herzen liegt, aber auch weil äh Daniel das Thema da sehr gut
erklärt hat.
Ähm außerdem natürlich die Seite Support Dot Records im Inciation Dot com, wo es ein sehr schönes Video von der Support-Kampagne gibt. Und,
Der Vortrag von Daniel Domscheid äh zum Thema Migration und Internet,
Auf dem Zündfunk Netzkongress zweitausendfünfzehn, den wir auch in den Shownotes verlinkt haben. Ähm denn Refugees äh immencipation ist bei weitem nicht die einzige Initiative in diesem Bereich. Es gibt auch
andere Initiativen, die dann zum Beispiel dafür sorgen, OK, da muss dieser Internetanschluss auch mit 'n vernünftigen vernünftigen VPN versehen sein und wenn die, eh, wenn wir die schon ans Internet knallen, dann können wir Ihnen direkt auch nochmal 'ne
eine Blogging-Plattform schenken,
und sie und die Menschen dazu bringen, von ihrem Leben zu erzählen, ja, um diesen Austausch auch herzustellen und dieses dieses Bewusstsein der Bevölkerung ein bisschen zu stärken. Da gibt's also auch andere.
Es nicht unbedingt über Facebook zu machen, machen zu müssen.
Genau, um sie nicht direkt ins Facebook zu treiben, ja. Äh und ähm also es war ein sehr eindrücklicher Vortrag von Daniel, den ich da sehr ähm empfehlen möchte.
Ja, kurzer äh Nachtrag noch zum Schwammtaler. Das ist ein Podcast, der sich primär mit Crowdfunding auseinandersetzt
von David Skribaner und da gibt's auch 'ne ganze Menge andere überraschende Themen zu finden, also wenn ihr da ohnehin schon mal reinhört, dann gleich mal durch das ganze äh Projekt, das sind einige interessante Sachen zu finden,
So, jetzt hast du's ja schon äh erwähnt, Zündfunk äh Netzkongress, eine Veranstaltung, die letztes Wochenende stattfand. Ich wollte eigentlich ursprünglich auch hin, konnte dann aber kurzfristig leider nicht dahin fahren,
Da wird man uns ja eigentlich auch treffen, denn du warst ja auch selber da.
Ja, ich war da.
Was war so dein Eindruck? Zwei das dritte Mal schon, ne?
Dass ich da war? Nee.
Nein, aber es äh der Zündfundnetzkongress war jetzt nicht das erste Mal in dieser Form in München.
Ach so, ja, ja, das war der dritte Zündfunk-Netzkongress, ja? Hm, also ich habe,
Ich war erstmal sehr, wie gesagt, Daniels Vortrag habe ich jetzt schon erwähnt, Daniel Bergberg, den fand ich sehr ähm sehr anregend. Ähm.
Ähm.
Ich war auch sehr begeistert, dass äh Peter Sunde einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Der hat quasi am Samstagmorgen die Keynote gehalten zum Thema digitale Selbstermächtigung. Peter Sohne ist ja sowieso eines der leuchtenden,
Eines der leuchten Beispiele unserer Zeit und ähm er hat da einen,
Er hat sehr schön auch so über seinen eigenes so ein bisschen äh,
Revue passieren lassen, seine eigenen Aktivitäten. Was er so zu den verschiedenen Zeiten gemacht hat, die Pirate Bate Zeit, die Flatterzeit, äh,
Knastzeit, ja? Das ähm,
Welche schönen Hacks sie auch dann immer wieder an verschiedenen Stellen äh gefunden haben, sowohl in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit als auch in der in der juristischen Arbeit. Ähm das war einfach ein sehr, sehr
inspirierender Vortrag wie eigentlich alle Vorträge von äh Peter Sohne es sind, also den kann ich ähm,
sehr empfehlen, auch wenn er da jetzt natürlich auch zu einem sehr nüchternen äh zu einer sehr nüchternen Betracht, in einer sehr nüchternen Betrachtung mündet. Ähm.
Zum nächsten Beispiel gehst also Peter Sunde, also mit Flatter, ich weiß nicht, weiß nicht, ob das jeder so weiß, aber er gehört zu dieser ähm,
Gruppe von Gründern, bei äh Flatter, allerdings war seine ähm Tätigkeit mehr ähm,
in der Öffentlichkeit,
also hat sich nicht so sehr mit der Entwicklung beschäftigt, das haben andere gemacht, aber Peter Suhne ist halt derjenige, der vor allem die Kunde nach außen getragen hat und der auch inhaltlich konzeptionell von Anfang an äh dahinter stand und ähm wahrscheinlich
auch äh treibenden Kräfte war, das weiß ich im Einzelnen nicht, die sich dieses Modell überhaupt erst ausgedacht haben. Auch als Folge der Pirat Bay äh Diskussion,
Ähm und wer jetzt für den ganzen Vortrag vielleicht keine Zeit hat, es gab dann, weil er da war, auch noch einen Artikel in der äh S Z,
macht kaputt, was eure Daten sammelt und man muss ja auch sagen, er ist ja jetzt seit dem ersten Gefängnis rausgekommen ist, vor allem dadurch aufgefallen, dass er sehr pessimistische äh Sicht der Dinge ähm Bezug auf das,
die weitere Entwicklung des Internets äh an den Tag legen, ja, vor allem schon ein bisschen kalter Schauer über den Rücken laufen kann, aber es sind auf jeden Fall alles auch sehr treffende Analysen,
Ich tue den Link auf diesen Artikel auch nochmal mit dazu. Was war noch da auf dem Netzkongress?
Intel Exit ähm also äh Jean Peters von hatten äh Vortrag über Intellexit gehalten. Also auch da natürlich für diejenigen, also
zwei Spendenaufrufe in einer Sendung, ja, Geflüchtete oder intellexit oder beides, ja.
Ja, wir können auch einen Dritten hinterherwerfen.
Ja, warte mal nur, warte mal, warte mal. Ich will, ich will hier schön das,
Ähm wenn ihr.
Wenn die Leute ihre Taschen sowieso schon geöffnet haben.
Genau, aber da kann man sich also zu beiden möchte ich äh nahelegen, sich zu informieren, um zu überlegen, wo man sein äh Geld dann äh,
hinwirft. Äh genau, zu also Intel Exit, Painkollektiv gab's äh auch einen Vortrag, der,
glaube ich, sehr gut angekommen ist und äh ich habe auch einen Vortrag gehalten, aber äh mir schwankt gerade Böses, weil ich den Eindruck habe, dass also er ist auf jeden Fall zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht veröffentlicht
und ähm wenn ich mich an ein vorsichtiges Gespräch,
Erinnere, was die Verwendung einiger Fotos in meinem Vortrag angeht, dann habe ich den einen habe ich die Befürchtung,
dass denen irgendwie die Eier fehlen äh meinen Vortrag zu veröffentlichen, was äh mich äh dann doch ärgern würde.
Ich spreche das mal hier so als äh äh Drohung ohne weitere ähm ohne weitere Substantivierung aus.
Das ist aber nur vergessen worden, das kann ja auch sein.
Das äh glaube ich nicht. Das könnte das Handy noch nicht,
Ich bin mal gespannt, vielleicht passiert's auch noch, ne? Also, ich meine, ist bayrischer Rundfunk, ne, den fällt äh wahrscheinlich um vier der Hammer aus der Hand und dann müssen wir mal gucken, äh ob da nochmal Bewegung reinkommt in den Laden, so.
Genau. Unsere Hörer können ja nochmal freundlich nachfragen beim Zündfunk. Sie hätten da gehört, es gab da einen Vortrag und äh der ist doch bestimmt ganz toll gewesen, weil der ist ja von Linus.
Vielleicht Freunde also ich sage mal so, vielleicht wollen die mir auch echt den Arsch retten, weil ich glaube, wenn der Vortrag dann irgendwann mal öffentlich ist.
Hagelt es Abmahnungsklagen.
Nicht Abmahnungen, aber da werde ich auf jeden Fall nochmal Flack für kriegen von einigen Leuten. Da freue ich mich jetzt schon drauf.
In Bezug auf die Bilder oder in Bezug auf den Inhalt.
Eher auf den Inhalt, ne, wenn.
Ach so. Du meinst es eigentlich ganz gut so, dass du dich veröffentlicht wird?
Nö, da habe ich äh da habe ich äh eigentlich keine Sorge, aber naja.
Andere vielleicht. Andere haben.
Na, ich habe gesagt, der Lutz Bachmann soll mal kommen.
Hatte da so eine kleine Facebook-Seite von ihm, äh auf der ich mich wiedergefunden habe. Also es war schon ganz amüsant eigentlich, hatte mir das extra für diesen äh Vortrag aufbewahrt,
insofern wäre das sehr ärgerlich, wenn wenn das jetzt nicht veröffentlicht werden würde, aber wahrscheinlich für mich besser, weil wenn jetzt irgendwie äh,
Ne, eigentlich will ich mit den Spinnern ja nichts zu tun haben. Ich bin ja, also keine Ahnung. Ah, gespannt.
Genau, wir sind gespannt. Gucken wir mal äh, was so bei rauskommt. Äh ansonsten müssen wir jetzt mal hier den Sack zumachen, weil die Sendung ist schon viel zu lang.
Also dein, deine Schuld.
Wieso meine Schuld? Quatsch. Ja. Watten?
Ich war pünktlich hier. Also meine Aufträge erfüllt.
Also ich glaube, das sind jetzt echt alle Vorträge online.
Was hat denn die letzte Sendung gehört? Selbstverständlich war ich die letzte Sendung. Warst du zu.
Selbstverständlich habe ich die letzte Sendung gehört. Ich habe sie verblockt bei Netzpolitik org. Wenn dir das nicht äh na?
Sehr schön. Doch ist mir aufgefallen. Das heißt ja nicht, dass du sie gehört hast.
Ich bin dann bin ich hier irgendwie so ein Schnellverlinker.
Keine Ahnung.
Nee, ich habe das schon äh selbstverständlich ähm mir angehört und habe mich natürlich sehr gefreut. Es gab auch ähm,
Journalisten, die ähm mir ihren Respekt gezollt haben, dass äh dass wir äh.
Zeitnah Herrn Srims.
Zeitnah einen Schreibstar hatten.
Tja. So ist es.
So ist das, wenn man äh ja, für eine ernstzunehmende.
Ja, wenn man nur in Nischen berichtet, dann kriegt man da nicht so den schnellen Zugriff, ja. Wir als Massenmedium. Genau. Haben da einfach ganz andere Möglichkeiten. So sieht's nämlich aus.
Ja, das.
Jo, hey.
Nee, es war net, weil war natürlich sehr schön und also Markus Lanz rief dann auch noch an und war war beleidigt.
Ja, schlimm schlimm.
Gut, aber ich meine gut, das hat er, das hat er sich auch selber zuzuschreiben.
Ciao. Aber aber nur wenn das Video danach auch veröffentlicht wird.
Okay, ich will jetzt hier nicht äh den den Zündfunkleuten jetzt schon irgendwie an die Karre pissen, aber wenn die jetzt echt diesen Vortrag nicht veröffentlichen wegen der Bilder, ähm.
Gibt's alles.
Nö, dann muss ich das halt machen.
Wieso hast du eine Aufzeichnung?
Müssen die mir das geben, wenn sie sich jetzt nicht trauen, dann äh würde ich.
Du dich dann einfach.
Ja, ich sehe da jetzt nicht das Problem,
Aber was ist auch sein kann? Ich habe ihn, also was auch sein kann, um das nochmal zu deren äh Schutz zu sagen, äh vielleicht verpixeln sie gerade alles, weil ich habe ihnen gesagt, dann verpixelt halt die Bilder, wenn ihr euch nicht traut. Dann wart,
Es ging dabei darum, dass es natürlich auch ärgerlich, dass sie den Vortrag im Fernsehen senden wollen. Im bayrischen Rundfunk.
Ah. Ach echt, die wollen die nassen Kongresse im Fernsehen ausstrahlen? Den ganzen Kongress. Sondern nur deinen dabeitrag.
Nein, nicht den ganzen Kongress. Diesen Beitrag wollen und eine und die anschließende Diskussionsrunde.
Ist er deshalb noch nicht auf YouTube, weil er sie erst im Fernsehen senden wollen, weil es wichtiger ist.
Nee, das haben sie sich, glaube ich, aus dem, das haben sie sich direkt gespart mit dem, also als sie gesehen haben, oh, Bilder richten, naja.
Mysteriös, was da abgelaufen ist. Welcher war da gewesen?
Ich fand das, also es war ganz, ich fand das ganz ähm,
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz interessant, dass also es lag bei mir vielleicht auch am Thema, aber da da waren halt die ganzen Social Media Betreuer von öffentlich-rechtlichem Rundfunk. Alle, glaube ich.
In meinem Vortrag und sonst keiner. Na ja.
Wir müssen zum Ende kommen. Ähm.
Genau, dann bleibt an dieser Stelle wie immer der Dank der ähm in dieser Woche Sören und Ralf gilt.
Und wie immer auch allen anderen, die diese Sendung ähm so.
Ausführlich und schön und liebenswert. Ähm unterstützen.
Und ähm wir haben vor dieser Sendung so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie wir das eigentlich weiterhin vermitteln wollen, dass bestimmte Personen ähm namentlich genannt werden, während es uns natürlich,
Insgesamt unmöglich ist, alle immer namentlich zu nennen, weil einige auch ähm anonym äh,
unterstützen und äh oder über Fletter, wo äh die Zahlen dann doch sehr hoch sind und die Beträge doch sehr gering. Ähm
sodass es halt oder der Gesamtbetrag sehr gering ist. Die einzelnen kennen wir ja nicht, sodass es äh eine Gradwanderung ist und wir sind da ergebnisoffen und bleiben jetzt erstmal bei unserer bisherigen
undurchschaubaren Geheimpolitik.
Bis es was besseres.
Bis uns was besseres einfällt ähm unseren ausführlichen Dank.
Und die emotionale Verbundenheit, die damit einhergeht, auszudrücken, dass äh überhaupt irgendjemand auf dieser Welt diese Sendung für unterstützenswert hält.
So sieht's aus. Also, jetzt haben wir genug gesagt. Bis bald. Vielen Dank, bis bald. Tschüss.
Vielen Dank, bis bald.